Ladies and gentlemen,
what the Fuck's going on?
So this up.
I'm sorry for the late start.
We were all fucked up.
We had a,
we weren't all fucked up,
but the cam is all fucked up.
That a problem with the Webcam,
but we're is high right now and I'm back
from Abu motherfucking dobby son.
That was very strange.
Scary at all.
It's scary.
It scared me,
man.
I mean it's A.
I mean it's real safe and it's real
western over there.
But the bottom line is that place is the
first time when we were done the first
time he muted the live preview.
Yeah.
So we don't hear ourselves.
But um,
we uh,
we got over there and it's very strange.
First of all,
we're at a place called Yas Island,
which is a manmade island.
They said,
which means they built an island.
Isn't it sinking?
Is that the one that's the one in Dubai,
the ones you buy the sinking is the one.
They have a model of the world.
If you ever wanted to know how much
money is an oil,
right,
you gotta go to the Middle East.
I'm sure that it's fucking staggering.
Really.
I didn't see a shitty car while I was
there.
Everything was a fucking Mercedes.
It's a Mercedes or A.
I guess the cabs are kind of crappy,
but it's all for robberies and
lamborghinis and these fucking
buildings.
They built this island.
Okay.
And then they have this thing called
Ferrari world and that's where the UFC
was,
which is this crazy theme park.
They're building.
They're just building shit constantly.
Everywhere you go.
They're building,
you know,
like all throughout the city of Abu
Dhabi.
It's all just skyscrapers and cranes and
shit going on constantly.
Apparently Dubai's buys even crazier.
I didn't want to fuck around with Dubai
dough.
I didn't even want to fly in there.
One of them,
one of the options was we could fly into
Dubai and then from Dubai we would take
a car service that would take us a
dress.
It's like an hour and a half drive to an
island and I was like,
I don't want to land in Dubai,
man.
I can't keep hearing crazy shit about
Dubai.
I hear crazy shit about people who got
arrested because there was some sort of
a visa problem,
so they drug test them.
They arrested this one woman for coding.
She is.
She lives in the UK.
She has a prescription for codeine
because she's got a back problem,
got back injuries.
So they arrested her for this and put
her in fucking jail because she had it
in her system.
Wow.
There's another guy who was traveling
there who had a speck of marijuana on
the bottom of his shoe.
But if you look at the dude,
that dude was like a roster.
He had dreadlocks and shit and that does
not fly.
Did you vacuum out your suitcase on my
God that I didn't smoke pot for a whole
day to day.
Crazy.
That was out of my head.
Yeah,
that's shit.
Just that shit scares me.
There's no reason to be put into that
because I've heard too many horror.
It's not a regular society.
I mean it's run by kings and you know,
for the most part they're running just
like western democracy means most,
you know,
it's very clean and very safe and cops
are everywhere and people are polite.
But the bottom line is you don't have
the same sort of rights you have in
America,
you know,
we always want to talk about are
dwindling rights and our rights are
certainly dwindling,
but they're still way better than what
you'd get over in Dubai.
Dubai,
you don't get shit it a couple of weeks
maybe out on the piece.
Now they're in jail.
That's where we're making out.
And then they,
they,
they said you can't do that.
We're going to put you in jail.
So they don't have a problem with like,
you know,
like the ring card girl is wearing.
I was wondering because I didn't talk to
anybody before,
I'm like,
what am I going to wear?
This chick's gonna wear like dresses.
Like how weird would that be if they had
a world like that would've been awesome.
Yeah.
They gave me the dress thing,
the,
the traditional garb,
and there was a guy who does my job for
the Arab world.
Very nice guy.
Uh,
his name was Muhammad and the,
they call them husband and they call
them Muhammad Rogan and uh,
it's hilarious.
And he,
he does the whole outfit and when he
does his broadcast,
he does this traditional Arab where they
all were.
It's like a white outfit with like a
black thing around your head and then a
white headdress,
I don't know what's called but everyone.
Whereas there did it smell okay over
there dude,
it's a bunch of rich people with crazy
money and weird outfits,
you know?
And I kind of liked the outfit for
certain.
This is what I liked about the outfit.
I like it because like you can't,
I mean I guess you could wear like a big
watch or something like that.
But like stylistically everyone looks
the same and there's something about
that.
Something about that is dumb.
It's like you should be able to dress
and look however you want,
but something about that is kind of cool
because it's like,
is it really fucking important what you
wear?
It's not,
it's like it's in your head,
it's nonsense and all this style and
like how you want to be portrayed.
Like have you ever seen a dude who like
wants to be thought of as like a writer,
you know,
wants to be thought of as like an
intellectual.
She's wearing like a jacket with the
Elbow Jack.
Carol whack.
Yeah.
Or that.
It's like just a certain amount of like
pretense that comes with what you were,
you know,
that's unavoidable.
You know,
I dress like I'm fucking 20 years old.
I mean I'm 42 fucking years old.
I still dress exactly the same.
I did when I was 20.
If you look at my wardrobe when I was 20
and now the only difference is I have
more clothes now.
That's it.
And I have a lot of tap out shit.
But other than that it's I fucking
dressing same.
I,
there's something about wearing that
outfit that they're all in unity to.
It's like they all recognized like we're
all in this together,
like we all have the same outfit on.
I mean part of it is like,
it's got to be bad for like creativity
and individuality and stuff like that
because one of the reasons why people in
America are so creative is [inaudible].
If you want to,
you could put a lip ring in and fucking
shave half your head and paint the other
half purple and Tattoo your face.
You can do whatever the fuck you want
over here and something about that as
good for creativity
to the point I understand,
but also I've had jobs where I've had to
have a uniform and was so much better
having a uniform or wearing the same as
everybody else instead of having to like
pick out a different tie every day and
every day for work.
Yeah,
that is true,
but if you had to choose when you're
working between having a uniform and not
having a uniform,
you're always going to say no.
No,
I don't know.
That's what I was saying.
I think I like having a uniform at work
because then kids,
you have to dress up,
right?
What if you could drag a real job,
and I'm talking about real world,
real world in the real world.
We live in a fake.
It's not a no.
That is another thing though about the
world is that the world is so.
It's so God damn rigid and what you're
supposed to wear and high supposed to
behave and how you're supposed to dress
like Jesus fucking Christ.
Like what?
That's the best way they have of
controlling people really is to make
sure that you're always going to wear
suits and ties when you go to work and
that you know,
you can't get into this place because
you have a hat on and you know,
I hate the hat on thing.
So silly that.
I mean because I could understand where
like you're in some parts where you're
like,
oh,
that guys might get mad at the other guy
because they're in a different gang or
something.
Or Gotham.
Take your hat off.
Yeah.
They wanted me to take off my hat and I
was with you at a comedy
club and he works for me.
It was ridiculous.
It was,
um,
we were,
uh,
at um,
what,
where the fuck was it?
Well,
that's the most ridiculous one.
Strip clubs or another ridiculous thing
that happens too.
If you go to a strip club,
they tell you to take your hat off now.
What did they tell you to turn it
around?
That's my other favorite.
If you were in it like I'm wearing
sometimes.
So can you please turn your head around
sir?
Yeah.
Because like,
oh,
now you got me now.
Normal.
One of the funniest things ever.
This is 100 percent true story.
My ex fiance and me went to a bar once
and they,
we drove all the way to oxnard or
something like that and we get there as
a friend's birthday and they're like,
sorry sir,
you can't come in.
You don't have a collar on your shirt.
And I'm wearing a tee shirt.
I'm like,
what?
We drove an hour and a half to get here
for a friend's birthday.
And you say I can't come in and it was
like all the stores around it were
closed because it was ochsner at nine at
9:00
PM.
So I went to my car to try to find a
shirt and only thing could find is my ex
fiance shirt and it was like a small
little tiny collared shirt that he wore
for work.
Right.
So I was like fat man putting on this
shirt.
It wouldn't even fit it look like that
old Chris Farley like fat man in the
jacket thing.
Like I couldn't button it up and it had
a color this and I put the collar up and
I seriously walked up to the door like
this and I'm like,
hi color shirt.
Can I come in?
And you're like,
yeah,
I guess so.
They let me in wearing just a great tee
shirts.
I now look like a fucking freak walking
around the Bargo Hey,
can I get a bug light and stuff.
Lead is the collared shirt story.
Like
what?
What the fuck is that about?
Why?
Why is it collar boat and no color?
I don't know.
Especially,
wouldn't you just be like,
alright,
you know what,
just take off that.
Just go in.
So ridiculous.
The thing about,
uh,
the Middle East is that you don't have
to wear that outfit.
When they gave me the head dress,
they gave me one.
When I got there I was like,
okay,
am I going to do I wear this when I'm
here?
Like that would be hilarious if we did
it like that.
Me and Mike both work,
but no,
nobody had to wear it but you know,
it people were and some people don't,
but a lot of people do when you go to
the mall.
So like I'd say like 30 or 40 percent of
the people were wearing it.
Wow.
It's weird.
So like,
do they look down on people that don't
wear it?
Like I don't know.
I do get more trouble if you wear normal
clothes.
I want,
that's a good question.
Yeah,
maybe.
Right.
Or maybe getting more triple where that
shit because you're right.
Fuck up the whole scene.
Right?
Blow on the curve,
man.
I think it'd be great because they would
feel like you're wearing pajamas
everywhere,
just be naked underneath it.
It's probably something to do with the
heat,
you know,
because it's a really light thing and it
doesn't stick to you and it,
you know.
I don't know.
I guess they're probably naked under it
if you want them to.
Yeah,
if you want it to be naked under that,
that actually pretty dope.
Yeah,
probably perfect for that kind of
weather flapping around ball sweat,
hitting your shoe to it.
It's hot as fuck over there and I don't
even think we're in the summer,
but there's first of all the billions of
mosquitoes there.
We got lucky and we didn't get hit,
but they said you can get,
you can get fucked up like a swarm of
them like swarm on you and you'll get
like a thousand bikes all over you.
There was wasps that were flying around
the cage at that big.
I was freaking out because it makes you
realize like,
oh yeah,
like we're in the fucking Middle East.
You know what I'm saying?
We're like east of Africa,
you know?
Whoa.
DC camels and shit everywhere.
I didn't see camels,
but some guys went and rode on camels
and shit.
Next sex and the city takes place there
at my life.
Really?
Yeah.
Those dirty bitches to ground over that.
It gets Dick.
Apparently.
There's a tremendous amount of hookers
and Dubai,
Dubai's like hooker central.
It's like there's hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of hookers.
So you go into like bars and clubs,
they don't have clubs and the clubs are
attached to a hotel.
So you go in the club,
it's attached to a hotel and just you
get,
just get swarmed by Russian hookers.
Wow.
Because there's so many rich dudes over
there and that's what it's all about.
It's about rich students do in business
and they feed off them and suck their
cock and milk money out of them.
Wow.
And you know,
get some cash.
Were at the comedy store the other day
and it's really hot.
Chick was all over my friend Jason and
the team and everyone was like,
damn,
he likes,
she likes him,
Blah Blah Blah.
And then finally like,
and he's like,
groping her and stuff and he must have
said something to her because at the end
she goes,
you have to pay to play.
And he goes,
what?
And then he doesn't know what.
And then she gets all right,
nevermind.
And walks away.
And then this is like a half hour of
presale that she did to him and no one
saw it coming.
It was like,
wow,
this,
this is cool.
How much money?
I don't know.
I don't think he,
I think he just went what?
I cannot afford cigarettes.
But they are you talking about?
Yeah,
there's a lot of that over in the Middle
East though.
That shits.
It runs rampant.
Makes Sense.
So many dudes with money,
you know,
they have the biggest building in the
world is Dubai.
It's a half a mile high.
Is that the one that the
golf thing.
Oh,
that's another one I think.
I don't think that's the same one,
but there is one with a tennis tennis
courts architecture out there.
It's just an amazing.
Off the chain.
Yeah.
They have so much money.
They have more money than you could
possibly imagine,
but apparently it's all dried up
apparently.
It's crazy now that so many people owe
money over there and if you get,
if you go broke over there,
you don't go to court and file for
bankruptcy,
you know,
you go to fucking jail,
they put your ass in a cage.
They put you in what's called debtors'
prison.
And debtors prison is a,
something you really want to avoid.
So when people are going into the hole,
they just drive their fucking four hours
to the airport and gone.
Wow.
So there's Ferrari's abandoned at the
airport,
like day people are constantly
abandoned.
The luxury cars leaving their houses,
you know,
they show up to,
to collect money and there's no one
there and they're gone.
They moved to Africa,
so it's been good,
nutty,
bad.
But uh,
they have nobody.
Shit like a indoor ski facility.
Like you can go skiing and doors.
That's about,
as I've seen this before,
apparently it's,
you have to see to believe how big it.
Right,
right.
It's actually like a,
there's a picture of it.
We could probably,
somebody could probably Google it where
it's just like a huge,
like slope and it's like a diamond all
the way down.
It's crazy.
Go surfing indoors to somewhere there.
What'd you do?
I still don't personally.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
So anyway,
so that was what the Middle East was
like.
It was.
People were very friendly over there.
Food was fantastic.
You know,
the hotels,
top notch.
It was only,
well I guess there were some people that
were there that weren't there for the
fights,
but not,
it wasn't crowded.
What's illegal?
Alcohol.
Illegal out there.
Alcohol,
you don't,
you can't go to bars but they have bars
at your hotel,
but that's the only place they have bars
is in hotels.
I think that's the law.
You cannot have a bar,
but you can have a bar inside of a hotel
for I guess for Westerners,
but they have like,
you know,
regular.
The food was great,
the beer was great.
It's like a regular.
Yeah,
everything tastes okay.
Like it tastes like Cola and everything
as Arab riding on it.
That's weird.
He's taken some of that for what could
doing for your scrap book,
what are you talking about?
What are you 12?
So that the arena was outside though,
right?
There was no risk to that.
I didn't even,
it was,
was outside.
And that was an interesting part of it
too,
because the first fight,
uh,
was uh,
John.
God dammit,
I forgot his last name.
He fought for the ultimate fighter
anyway,
and Mustapha Al Turk and uh,
the first fight,
these guys were so fucking slippery.
They were punching and as they were
punching sweat was flying off them
because they were the first guys to
fight.
And so they were fighting like basically
in the sunlight and it was know fucking
a hundred degrees outside and humid and
that,
that had to affect their fight for sure.
Yeah.
They pace themselves,
you know,
and then they got through it.
But,
uh,
John Madsen,
thank you very much sir.
Um,
and the John Madsen,
Mustapha Turk was a fight and they were
so sweaty and every time they threw
punch,
sweat was fucking flying off.
And literally like they threw water,
like they were throwing cups of water at
each other.
It was fucking crazy.
So that's the.
So that's the reason why the guy who
fought Silva went into lay down the
whole time.
No,
I just sat there and I got to talk about
that.
That's a very controversial fight.
I,
I rewatched the fights last night.
I rewatched a Bj Penn,
Frankie Edgar,
and I rewatched a Anderson Silva and I'm
Damien Maia and the Frankie Penn,
Bj,
the Frankie Edgar,
Bj Penn.
A lot of controversy on that fight.
One of them is [inaudible] doug crosby,
who's A judge who's a friend of mine.
I like him.
He scored it 45 to 50,
meaning he gave every single round to
frankie edgar.
Now I thought it was way closer than his
way closer than that.
I watched the game last night in person.
I was like,
man,
I don't know.
When I saw it in person,
I was like,
look,
the kid did fantastic.
He definitely did better than anybody
expected.
Um,
but the thing is when you're doing
commentary for fights,
basically I'm just kind of explaining
what's happening,
I'm sure to keep an italian my head,
but what I'm concentrating on most is
explaining things,
being entertaining,
you know,
trying to,
trying to do good commentary.
Not really scoring is done silently,
you know?
Correct.
Scoring is done silently because you're
contemplating what's,
what's more valuable.
I mean it's,
a lot of it is subjective,
but you have to contemplate,
okay,
a guy throws a punch and the guy,
the other guy counters with a leg kick.
Which one was harder?
Which one?
You know what I'm saying?
It's like,
who do you give it to with some people
give the punch to it,
some people will give the leg kick and
in that case I could see how it would be
closer,
you know,
then then I thought it was when I
watched it last night,
but when I watched the last night,
I thought it was three rounds to two for
bj penn.
That's what I thought.
I mean,
I,
I think there's been clOser ones before
to me,
I could have taken either way,
either way.
It wasn't ridiculous to me that he won,
but 45 to 50 was ridiculous and the
reason why I say it wasn't as ridiculous
because like when I was calculating when
I was watching it,
like in the first round,
he lands a really nice leg kick at one
point and then bj hits him with a punch
and bj hit him with a couple of other
punches during the take downs and he had
pj with a few punches and one of them
cut him.
So that probably affected people because
bj had like a little mark under his
face.
So sometimes judges look at that and I
go,
yeah,
he got the best of that round just
because a little cut sometimes that
affects them.
So you know,
it's so subjective man.
But then the second run I was like,
bj's landed more punches.
They're like lending more,
frankie's throwing more and he's moving
more.
He's making bjj fighters fight.
He's definitely making bj chaser.
So you're going to take that into
account.
Who's,
who's doing better there?
Who's got better ring generalship or
control the octagon while bj's,
the one forcing the fight.
He's chasing after him,
but frankie is really avoiding too much
damage,
but I think the cleaner shots were
landed by bj and then as it got into the
later rounds,
dennett seemed like frankie,
the only round that was really clear to
me,
it was the fourth or the fifth round
rather.
The fifth round was clear.
That was all edgar.
He took him down.
He landed some real good shots.
It was a good round.
It seemed like around for him where
where bj was fading every other round,
but the fifth was like,
man,
who fucking knows?
Well,
it's kind of like if you see a fight at
a cafeteria,
you're not talking about the first five
minutes of a fight.
You're talking about what that the end
of the fight is dominating.
And that's a very good point.
That's a very good point.
And you know what?
A lot of people feel like fights should
be scored that way,
that they're different than,
than any other sport.
And at the end really is what matters
because they'd been imposing their will
on each other and here's the end result.
The end result of 25 minutes of imposing
their wills with frankie edgar was
kicking bj's ass,
set them down.
He led,
kicked him.
He was moving better.
You know,
he,
he in the end,
you know,
bj chased after him with a very few
final seconds,
but he knew that it was the final
seconds.
I would love to hear bj's,
not the type of guy to make excuses
other people.
That's true.
Vaseline.
Well,
but that might've been true though.
Let's be honest.
It was true.
They rub it on the guy's face and you
see,
rub it on the guy's chest and rubbed it
on the guys back.
Just kidding.
I know that's 100 percent illegal.
And I love phil nurse.
I think he's a great coach.
I love gsp.
Those to both of them.
But you can't do that.
I believe when they say that this
fucking witch Dr.
Guy tells them to do this thing because
he explained it to me.
He explained to me this weekend,
it seems like total malarkey.
It's like,
you know,
he's telling me that there's three
minds.
There's a mine here,
mine here in a mind here,
and there's pressure,
builds up the chain and you have to
release and you grab here and you press.
You know why that works?
It works if you believe it works.
That's why that works and there's a lot
of shit like that.
Like I know a dude who's a chiropractor
slash healer and a lot of people swear
by them and the reason why they swear by
them is because if you believe that what
he's doing is going to heal you.
Your body has amazing ability to heal
itself.
Negative and positive thinking and
negative and positive beliefs about your
life are without a doubt,
self fulfilling prophecies.
You can decide that your life is awesome
and your life becomes awesome.
Now if you decide that your life sucks,
you can decide that your healing and
your heel,
you can decide that you're not in pain
and you won't be in pain and you can
make pain happen,
especially when it comes to like back
shit and you know there's real injuries
and people get in car accidents and
fucking jujitsu.
You get your neck cranked.
But there's also people that create back
injuries to avoid their life,
like they don't want to think about
reality.
So ah,
my fucking back.
And that keeps them from thinking about
other shit.
But anyway,
that's why they do this thing where you
press ahead and that's what that's all
about.
It's like some psychosomatic thing,
but it's a placebo if,
if,
if you believe in it,
man,
it fucking works.
So I would like anyone.
I would like to talk to bj and find out
how was he in shape because he didn't
look as good as it usually looks.
I mean he didn't look fat,
but he didn't look as hard as he looked
in the sanchez find the sessions feisty.
He looked sculpted and this fight he had
a little bit of a belly,
like a little bit of fat on his way,
so maybe he had an injury because he
also didn't sit down and his stool in
between rounds,
which I thought was unusual.
Was it him that had the thing you had a
nice sleeve on and he didn't sit down in
between rounds and which you rounds.
He stood up and he put his leg up,
put his leg up on the stool and they
said that to him at one point in time.
Bj,
put your leg up,
put your leg up.
There you go.
But I don't know what that means.
It could be a cramp.
It could be nothing.
It could be.
It's that human and you just got done
fighting.
You're going to want to sit down and he
can.
Yeah,
I would think so.
I don't know what it is,
but see he hasn't said a word about it,
so I don't know.
So I think I could easily see how
someone could give that fight to frankie
edgar.
It totally makes sense to me.
You know,
and I said like when I saw it live I was
like man,
I don't know either way,
but at the end of the fight edgar was
winning the fight and like you said,
that should count more.
That's the way pride scores that the way
to do it.
They counted the fight as like one whole
thing.
That's how it should be.
Totally.
I totally agree with you.
I think.
I think fights are not like any other
sport and that like there was a fight
between rio shown and a brad blackburn
once and brad blackburn was kicking his
ass for two rounds and then the third
and final round real children came on
strong and he battered black is beat the
fuck out of them.
Like really went after him and broke his
nose and he had him running from him.
Total domination.
The third route.
So it was so much difference between the
first two rounds which are pretty close
but blackburn was winning by,
was getting his shots in but jonah and
keep coming forward.
But blackburn was kicking his ass but
then the third real China just turned it
on.
But real lost the fight,
he lost a decision because blackburn one
the first two rounds and I said that's
the first.
See the clearest example to me of how
someone won the fight but lost the fight
at the same time.
He wanted a decision,
but he lost the fight.
If it was a fight.
That guy lost the fight.
Yeah.
What's crazy about imagine two guys
fighting and at the last second it got
hits.
A guy knocks him out right when the bell
hits,
you know.
But in the other guy won because he was
doing the rest of the fight better,
you know?
But if,
you know what I mean?
Like what if that were to happen,
what if that knocks him out?
He goes,
no,
no.
Right at the bell though,
like thing bam.
Guy knocks out,
you know the.
Yep.
Oh,
like after the break.
Right.
You know why you would say to the guy
dropped his guard because he heard the
bill.
No,
no.
If it was like full from that bank
thing,
bonk,
you know,
like
I think as long as he was already
committed to the punch before the bell
rang,
right,
it wouldn't be a problem.
But you know,
that would like some crazy last second
buzzer shit.
Right.
Because it.
Because liotta.
But cheetah did that.
He'd knocked out thiago silva at the,
like after barbara and he put them out.
It was like during the horn,
I think going off or,
or very close.
Very close within.
Why don't.
So has there been any talk about taking
the pride rules?
No,
no,
no.
What?
It's so hard to,
uh,
to reason with the people that are
involved and just sanctioning.
It's so hard to get things sanctioned.
And the thing I've said before,
people complained about elbows like this
elbow,
which is what they call the 12 to six
elbow coming straight,
straight down.
The only reason why that was made
illegal was because big John Mccarthy,
this came straight from his mouth when
he was educating the commission and they
were trying to,
you know,
legislate mixed martial arts.
The people in these athletic commissions
were worried that downward elbows on
espn at 2:00
in the morning can break bricks,
you know,
there's fucking karate demonstration.
So they were like,
well we can't have that because you can
hit someone and killed them.
Okay,
so you can't do that,
but you can still do this,
which is more powerful.
I think this is less powerful than this.
This right here.
It seems to get more weight into it.
It's a more natural motion.
This is pretty strong,
but I don't think it's as good as this.
It's like hitting someone in the head
like that is not as strong as hitting
them a lot.
That was like when you turn your body
into something,
you have more power and I think that
makes more sense that this elbow,
the elbow that jon jones broke brand and
various eye socket with.
That's the.
That elbow.
That's illegal elbow,
but it's powerful as fuck.
Like what?
Why is the other one illegal?
And this one's legal debts.
I kind of get it though because there is
a big reason why the ufc used to be on
an a vhs tape with faces of death in my.
In my collection.
That used to be shocking,
like almost disturbing,
like,
oh,
I don't want to watch because it was
like this guy could die,
you know?
No,
I definitely agree that there should be
rules and I definitely agree this should
be sanctioning,
but it should be rational shit.
It should be.
I don't think you should.
Soccer kick people in the ground,
right?
I don't.
I don't think,
but I do think that if a guy's on his
back,
he should be able to kick you in the
face.
Right?
If you're on your knees so loud,
you should still be able to kick you in
the face.
You're punching him in the face.
Why can't he kick you?
That's ridiculous.
If you are one nay,
you can blast someone in the face with a
punch.
Why can't he kick you in the face?
You're trying to hit him.
Well,
you can't move as good.
don't be there then.
That's ridiculous.
You're taking away a a,
an important weapon for the guy in the
bottom.
You should be able to up kick the fuck
out of someone when they're on their
knees.
If that guy's trying to punch you in the
face and you're lying on your back,
it's like your weight is on top of them
like you're stomping him.
You're kicking from your back at him.
You should be able to kick his fucking
head like a soccer ball when you're
lying on your back and a guy's on his
knees,
on top of you trying to punch you,
you should be able to kick the fuck out
of him and it should be much more.
Put yourself in much more jeopardy.
You're in much more danger when you're
on top of a guy then,
and that's how it should be because
that's how it is in real life.
That's how it should be.
It shouldn't be this unrealistic thing
where the guy has to be standing up over
you for you to kick in the face.
No,
it should be.
You could kick them as long as you're on
the bottom.
Is there the bottom you can kick them
and if you're on the top you can kick
everything except for his head and
that's what it is.
You can kick a guy in the body when he's
on the ground,
you know you can kick the guy in the
legs,
you can kick it down to opponent.
So a downed opponents should be able to
kick you anywhere from any,
anywhere.
Who wants?
It's legal.
There's a lot of rules.
I need to be changed though.
Like gracie's never tap.
Come on that last fight.
That fight that he wasn't going to tap
that.
That's one of those fights though that I
was like this.
All right,
there should be a cut.
Alright.
Fights over because there were so many
times where I'm like,
why is this guy even bother?
Let's finish with the frankie edgar.
Fight that fight though because I think
like I said,
scoring is a very subjective thing.
You could say the frankie edgar
outworked him because he threw more
punches and he landed leg kicks.
He didn't learn that many leg kicks.
Frankie definitely landed more leg
kicks.
He mixed it up more.
Take down attempts so I could definitely
see him winning the fight.
I could see it being an argument because
no one can say that.
Their opinion when something's that
close,
you can't really say that your opinions
right or wrong,
but the fifth round he won.
He won the fifth round.
I don't see how anybody could argue that
he didn't.
But doug,
this crosby men 50 to 45 minutes.
That's ridiculous.
That doesn't make any sense.
He must've been drunk.
That's why the reference should be done
by a 100 people.
Yes.
I think you're right.
I think three is too little and you know
another here's another problem.
Maybe the referee and should be done in
some sort of an online thing where
people they get picked.
Absolutely no,
like they get picked the the like
posters on message boards.
Guys who are big fans,
guys who really,
really understand the sport and we do it
electronically.
What's the.
What's the thing that's a measures,
a tv ratings and stuff and get a nielsen
box.
Something like that.
Pick only a certain amount.
I don't think it should be like millions
of people means like that though.
Your paper idea,
but you know what the problem is,
they all have to be there live to
really.
Then there's that too.
There's that argument.
There's that live is actually not as
good.
Oh,
you're not seeing the whole thing.
Not seeing the whole angles and you
don't get to see a monitors.
You know,
like when you live.
Like when I'm doing commentary,
I've got two monitors to my to my right
and one to my left.
So there's,
there's all sorts of angles.
Like sometimes we're looking at a fight
and we're watching it live through the
cage and write some shit goes down,
they'll move in front of a barrier or
they're moving in front of one of the
polls and I can't see shit for a second
and then I have to turn to the monitor
or they're on the ground and from the
angle where I'm at,
all I see is one the side of a person's
body,
like they're on the ground,
but they're on the other side of the
octagon.
I can't say it.
So I have to look to the monitor,
the judges don't get that,
they don't get monitors.
So these guys are just watching the
fight as it's happening from the angle
that they get and ever.
And you know,
I argued with the fucking,
the athletic commission guy about it and
he's like,
well,
you know,
um,
the,
this is the,
you know,
that's why we have three judges.
So they all have different angles.
No,
because you're going to get shitty
handles,
give them fucking monitors that they
should have it like,
er style,
where the doctors are all above looking
down at the fight.
And we are absolutely.
But the problem is even if above you,
what you would really have to do is be
in there and we can't have that now
above with a monitor.
The cameras are better.
Really watching it,
watching it live is better for the
excitement.
Like there's nothing that beats that
It's fucking nuts.
You know,
and when you're there and you know,
fucking,
you know,
randy coture is stepping in to fight
brock lesnar and the place is going
bananas.
You know,
that's,
that's pretty intense.
You know that you can't recreate that at
home,
at home.
It's fun,
but when you're there live,
you feel like you're a part of history,
like you feel like you're a part of some
wild ass shit.
You know when shogun and machita fight
in montreal in may,
that being in that arena,
when those two guys step in there for
the rematch,
that's going to be everyone in the
fucking place is going to have
goosebumps.
That's going to be nuts,
man,
because they're going to know this is
history,
man.
These guys went at it for five fucking
rounds.
Everybody thought machida was totally
untouchable and then most people thought
shogun one of the decision and now
they're going out again and live and
it's happening right now.
Here we go.
Watch it at home.
It's pretty dope.
You know,
you get the commentary,
you get the replays,
you get,
you know,
get all the information,
but watching it live to some special
crackle in the air or your front row in
the middle.
Most of the time when I watched live,
I watched the monitors,
like I watch it while they're standing
up,
but once it's down I'm looking at the
monitor and the floor.
You're like right there and I'm only
like a couple rows,
you know,
but still I'm watching the monitor being
right there.
It's pretty dope to be able to look
through the cage.
It's almost worth keeping that ufc job
just for that.
Do you ever get like blood splat right
on your hit this weekend?
Oh,
you hit on my arm.
One of the prelims is licking out of it.
I told him,
give us a hot water,
get in my dna.
It was a um,
it was pretty intense.
Yeah,
there was a,
there was a lot of,
there was a lot of blood and a couple of
fights.
The,
that was in the um,
uh,
Paul Kelley.
Matt veech fight.
Matt beach had a horrible cut.
He had a couple of them and just
splattered they were right in front of
us and they're beating on each other and
just the blood went flying.
So that's my take on the controversy on
the frankie edgar,
bj penn fight.
I think frankie edgar,
frankie edgar flawed a hell of a fight.
It was a tremendous performance.
So super impressed with them.
Um,
but uh,
I'm not exactly sure if I agree with the
verdict.
I definitely don't agree with 50 45,
but I thought it was a very close fight
and obviously I'm not a judge so who the
fuck am I to judge?
And I definitely could see an argument
for frankie winning it.
And like I said,
he put on a tremendous fight.
I mean really impressive and definitely
one the last round.
So if you look at it in terms of like we
said,
you know,
someone that's the way it should be that
though the guy winds at last round wins
the fight.
I mean he's the,
they've,
they've imposed their will upon each
other and you know,
the end result is after all this time
this guy's dominating the other guy,
but cafeteria rules.
Then there's another school of thought
where you have to take the champions
title,
which I don't really agree with.
I think the decision should be clear,
but I think you go in neutral.
I think when a guy's a champion,
you go in neutral,
you know,
you're both go in neutral.
And if the champion,
you know,
if you win the decision,
you're the new champion.
If he wins the decision,
he's a new champion.
It doesn't have to be some crazy
domination,
you know,
because that's what leads to like shitty
decisions where a guy really does beat
the champion,
but he only agism and then he never gets
the.
You never get.
Those are frustrating as fuck because
you think he did it.
I think he did it.
The other problem with the frankie edgar
fight,
this was,
uh,
an interesting point is that when you're
watching a guy who you think is going to
get his ass kicked,
right,
a lot of people did.
A lot of people thought frankie edgar
was going to get,
you know,
bj penn is the greatest lightweight of
all time.
Frankie edgar got beat by gray maynard
and they're like,
yeah,
there's no way this guy's going to beat
him.
Right?
So people think that because he's doing
well,
he's winning like wow,
he's doing better than I thought it was.
So they say,
holy shit,
he's beating him,
he's beating them.
But when you go back and you watch it,
that's why it's so much more with so
much pressure to be a champion.
So much pressure.
I'll never forget this.
When bj penn beat matt hughes,
I interviewed matt after the fight and
matt said that he was relieved.
Yeah,
just all the groups were honest.
He said,
you don't know what it's like to be a
champion and everybody's gone in after
you.
He goes out.
To be honest with you,
I'm really relieved.
And I was really like,
first of all,
I was very impressed with his honesty.
You know,
that's a very honest thing to say,
you know,
when you're,
you just fought and you're standing
there covered in sweat naked in front of
the fucking whole world,
you know,
like,
I'm relieved.
I just lost right now I can catch a
breath,
relax.
And then it came back and won the title
again.
Know.
So I think he learned from the
experience,
but I think it's a tremendous amount of
pressure for guys to,
to fight and defend the title and to
always worry about defending the title,
especially in something like mixed
martial arts.
I mean it's probably a tremendous amount
of pressure if you're a fucking a
basketball team,
you know,
defending their,
their world championship.
But a fighter would use always guys
coming up,
they're gunning for you and every time
you watch a ufc there's some new
murderer who's head kick and dudes into
a fucking coma and he wants to do the
same shit to you and he's talking shit
about you calling you a faggot and a
bitch.
And I'm like,
jesus christ,
you know,
these guys get that.
That's why they're so god damn
sensitive.
Is that what's going on right now with
tito and adele,
isn't it?
It seems like it seems like a fighting,
fighting chocolate dough.
Oh really?
Not five chuckled though.
Chuck liddell is going to be fighting
rich franklin.
And I can only say this because it's
officially been released and was on the
ufc is website.
I can't say why.
And they've been going back and forth on
twitter.
I've been noticing it.
It's kind of getting.
Okay,
well that all all come out.
What happened in time.
I can't talk about it though.
It's um.
Oh yeah,
that's what it is.
So,
um,
anyway,
that's a,
that's that.
Um,
but you know,
when,
when dudes are defending their title,
I think there's a lot of emotions at
state and I think that's one of the
things that people have taken to
consideration with this anderson silva
fight.
You know,
anderson silva,
everybody's angry at him and every.
And it wasn't very disappointing fight,
especially because the first two rounds
he looked like,
like fucking Bruce Lee.
I mean it was like ridiculous shit.
He was eat that flying knee that he hit
him with the first round.
You're like,
jesus christ,
she's just going to steam roll this guy.
He's just going to keep doing this until
this guy just crumbles.
It's just gonna keep attacking at will
and he's breaking this dudes will.
It was totally humiliating.
But I think that the emotion of
defending the title,
the emotion and the pressure of being
regarded as the best pound for pound
fighter in the world,
I think that's an insane amount of
pressure.
I think it's insane.
And I think when damien maia said shit
to him,
like I'm like take one of his arms home
with me.
You know,
henderson got fucking crazy.
So then when he was in there after the
first rain after is kicking his ass and
the second round is just start just
talking mad shit and yelling at them in
portuguese.
I wish I understood what the fuck you.
It's not been translated yet.
Well some people have given a rough
translations of it on the internet,
but I don't know how you could possibly
hear.
I've watched the fight and I've turned
the volume of way up.
It's so hard to discern what he's saying
because there's no microphone on him.
He's not miked.
Headphones,
man.
And the crowd is screaming,
cheering,
and we're talking over him.
Right.
So me and mike were talking like,
what is he saying?
You know when he's going nuts,
screaming and yelling at,
even if you have headphones on,
I think it would still be hard screaming
and yelling at a damien maia and I guess
he was calling them like a spoiled rich
kid or something like that.
Like does damien miles like kim's for a
better upbringing?
I don't know what it was.
Where's your jujitsu now is another
thing that people are speculating who
saying like,
where's your jujitsu?
Where's it?
Bam.
Then kicks up.
Where did you get to
see?
I didn't have a problem with it.
Like I'm not on the boat.
That gain is on and everyone else's on
with it because I don't care about like
a respect thing to me.
If he can play fucking air guitar in the
ring,
you're putting up against somebody
that's not.
That shouldn't be there like that.
If you put him in with our caprock
that's just attacking him where he
doesn't have a chance to do all this fun
shit in the ring,
then that's different than that guy just
go into his back every time because he
wants to get do jujitsu.
I mean,
he,
if he doesn't want to,
you know,
he was laying on his back.
He kept on going to his back to me.
I was like to his
back as he failed to take down and he
has to do that.
He asked to fall backwards because if he
moves forwards is going to get punted.
He doesn't really.
That's really when,
when you pull,
when you shoot on a guy and you don't
get to take down.
What happens is like say say you shoot
the,
a guy who tried to get ahold of them,
he sprawls you have to follow it.
When a guy sprawls he kicks his legs
back.
When he kicks his legs back,
you have to follow his legs with your
legs to try to stay a hold of them.
Right.
But of course anderson knew this was
gonna happen and anderson is so much
more explosive and so much faster than
him.
Like,
like I've always said,
I think he's in the matrix.
Like I think he's just seeing this shit.
Like he can see something going on five
seconds before it happens and then I
think,
all right,
you got to get somebody that's in the
matrix.
Okay,
but how come he couldn't keep up
doing that because he didn't do that in
the fourth round.
Fourth round.
He got fucking pumped.
The fourth or the fifth you got hit with
a big ass lefthand,
right?
Yeah,
because he got stopped doing it because
he'd heard what all that people booing
adam and probably dana minded like got
up and left or something crazy like
that.
He probably is like,
alright,
I guess I have to get out of this matrix
for awhile and be somebody that I'm not
fucking you.
If you look how smooth and calm he was
up to about the fourth one,
then it seems like something happened
between the third and the fourth.
He was yelled at or something like that.
You got tired.
That's what happened.
He got tired.
We're outside.
It's super humid.
It's hot as fuck.
It's first time fighting outside.
It's,
you know,
he's gotten two rounds of clowning in
right now and you know,
I think all that energy that he,
he expended,
he could not keep up that kind of pace.
He was winning the fight based on sheer
explosion and absolutely,
totally avoiding any damage,
which is his style.
But then he got hit when he got hit in
the third round,
the fourth round rather,
I think it was a fourth of the fifth.
He got hit with a big left hand.
I think he shut down.
You haven't.
He was like,
fuck this.
I think he really decided like,
I forget my,
I can get hurt here,
you know,
like,
and he's tired.
Right.
You know,
so he just decided to keep moving.
I really do think that's what happened
because the fifth round he didn't do
jack shit,
you know,
and there was,
there was one segment where he was
standing over maya and maya was throwing
bombs that I'm from his knees.
Mine was throwing punches from his knees
and mine was just trying to fucking kill
him.
He just couldn't connect to them.
And in that kind of exchange,
normally anderson just lights dudes up,
that kind of exchange of guys coming and
attacking and bombing and he doesn't
counter.
Why isn't encountering he,
he's not,
he's tired.
That's what happened,
you know?
And now I don't hear a lot of people
saying this.
I think in the fourth and fifth rounds,
I think he was tired.
I think he was too tired to fight at his
normal pace,
which is his explosion inside and
outside his speed that he uses.
He's lightening fast math really dives
in like that.
He's so much faster than everybody else.
And that's one of the keys to his
countering.
But when he got tired,
he wasn't as fast anymore.
He just wasn't.
He lost a lot of esteem.
And I think he decided to just coast.
It was like,
fuck it,
I want this.
Right.
I'm just gonna
do you think that's his fault for being
able to coast?
It's a good point because,
I mean brocklin,
unless somebody coast for two to three
rounds,
neither would um,
fader fader would put a guy out,
he would,
it would find the guy and put a put feta
or you know,
is not afraid to get hit.
Anderson never gets hit or gets faced,
bust it up.
And then the brett rogers fight like
right on,
like first round,
first minute,
he got hit with a big jab and his nose
broke open.
He had a cut on his nose going into the
fight.
Anderson never gets caught.
He gets hit.
He got hit more on the damien mind
either that I ever recall him.
He definitely got hit harder when davy
there's,
there's one,
a animated gif online that someone found
of damien maia stepping in and,
and cracking silver with a big fucking
lefthand and it really hit them square
and silver wobbled and moved away and
started dancing.
That's the guy who got hit.
That's it.
I was tired and got hit.
I think he fucked around too much in the
beginning.
He blew a ton of energy.
We're outside.
It's humid.
And then I think psychologically he
starts thinking,
what the fuck am I doing?
You know,
I'm acting like an asshole and screaming
and yelling at this guy,
and then he stand in front of the dude
clown,
I'm going to get cracked.
And then I think he just decided to
move.
Just fuck this.
See,
I'm a huge fan still.
I don't,
I don't care what happened.
I think he,
if anything,
he learned his lesson and in this shit,
but I don't like all these people are
like,
you know,
blaming him for this and I,
I just don't see it.
I'm like,
why isn't the other guy,
the other guy let him.
I'll do all of this.
Here's the problem.
First of all,
it was a historic ufc.
He was the headline fight.
And one of the goals of course,
besides winning,
winning is the number one goal for a
fighter.
But the other goal is to entertain.
You have to realize that you're in a
partnership with the ufc and the ufc
sales paper view.
And what they say sell paper view on is
based on how impressive and exciting
your performance.
Yeah,
but when you see,
when you play easy and you just run
away,
you know,
an attack,
he could have finished that guy off in a
second round.
He could've maybe finished him off even
in the third round.
He had just put himself in danger and
he's not willing to put himself in any
danger and he's a well calculated
fighter.
I don't see the argument for that.
However,
for what he did in the fourth round and
the fifth round,
adults see an argument for because he
didn't do shit.
He didn't attack it all.
He didn't fight.
He literally didn't fight.
Maybe he couldn't,
you know,
I mean,
he definitely couldn't fight the way he
fought in the first two rounds and he's
not willing.
I think at this point in time with all
the pressure on him being widely
regarded as the best pound for pound
fighter in the world,
he's not willing to get an exchange.
You get cracked.
You know,
it's got a tremendous use for,
you know,
I see the entertainment thing,
but I also say,
hey,
is this entertainment part going?
Make me lose this fight?
Because if it is,
I'm not going to do that.
I mean,
look,
I think there's definitely some worry
about that.
I think he definitely was worried about,
you know,
if he was tired and if he was going to
those fourth and fifth rounds,
the only thing that makes sense to me is
that he moved around because he didn't
feel like he could fight at the pace
that he fought before.
And when that guy hit him,
he said,
you don't want it.
This isn't a game.
I could get hurt here.
I could lose and I would look completely
retarded.
So let's just around.
Fuck this guy.
I'll throw some faint,
I'll move around.
And you guys that have attacked him.
Yes.
He couldn't.
The bottom line with them in mind.
My has tremendous heart,
but his striking is so below what
anderson's is,
the only way it's gonna work is if
anderson's really tired and wasn't
willing to stand in front of him when
he's really tired.
So who do you think silver can fight?
That would just change the game.
The guy would come in there who won't
let silva do any of this shit.
Good question.
Some people say vitor belfort,
but the problem with vito belfort is
vituro has had some very uneven
performances.
Like sometimes he just looks like
unstoppable.
Like against rich franklin,
you know,
against vandelay silva.
He comes charging out in the first
round.
But sometimes I forget sakharova things
don't go his way and he kind of shuts
down and guys wind up beating his ass.
Like he broke his hand into sakharova
fight early and you could see him like
totally shut down.
And soc robin just kicked his ass,
you know,
and the randy couture torrified,
same thing.
Randy coture just broke up and got on
top of them.
It's just beat him up.
And his first fight with randy couture
and it's third fight,
the second fight,
but stop really quickly because it.
Randy had a cut on his eyelid.
Is eyelid opened up?
Like it was like split in the it like he
got greg glanced with a punch and then
vito became the champ for one fight.
And then when randy beat him up in the
rematch,
randy gun on top of him just broke them,
you know,
if,
if guys put a tremendous amount of
pressure on him in the past,
they've been able to break him.
But the other,
the other argument to that as he was
going through a tremendous amount of
personal problems back then,
he's a different guy now.
His,
his sister had been abducted and
kidnapped and killed and he was really
devastated for years,
you know,
and that he's over that now and it's
very religious and more at peace with
himself and more like in tune.
And his last few performances has been
staggering.
Like the matt lindland destruction,
he destroyed matt lindland.
He looked outstanding and then he came
to the ufc and destroyed rich franklin.
I mean he looks scary as fuck.
And anderson,
you know,
did not want that fight.
They were talking mad shit to each other
and they were at anderson's manager was
trying to say that victoria doesn't
deserve the title fight.
Like what are you talking about?
He's the scariest motherfucker.
One 85 besides anderson.
Of course he deserves it.
I don't think they wanted that fight.
I think the,
you know,
you,
they can talk all the shit they want
about him being weak and you know,
if he tours week and he breaks mentally,
he comes at you in that first round.
You have to fight him before you break
them.
Okay.
And before you break them,
he's throwing lightspeed fucking barrage
of punches like no one else in the
business.
He's scary as fuck.
And if he really is a better,
more mature person,
if it really is more centered now and
he's not going to break and really is
like at home with themselves and really
his problems in the past where he was
going through a lot of emotional and
personal problems.
But those have actually made him
stronger.
If that's the case,
everybody's fucked because that guy's a
freak.
He so fucking fast.
He might be the only guy that's faster
than anderson.
He's a counter striker and he's not as
long as anderson.
So anderson would have a little bit of
advantage and a reach advantage,
but goddamn v towards fastest fuck
athlete John Jones,
a freak to to put John Jones is two.
Oh five.
John jones can't make one 80 foot gsp
versus silicon that ever happen.
He was going to happen.
That's what happened.
It was going,
no,
they'll never do that.
Now they can't trust anderson.
Now they can't trust him to perform.
And this is what I was saying before,
this is why this fight was so important.
This is why they're so pissed.
Okay?
Because the last two rounds,
you know,
him just running away the ufc his own 10
percent of his own by flash
entertainment,
which is the royal family in abu dhabi.
And this was like a huge showcase for
them.
This was like their big acquisition,
you know,
they're partners now and they're going
to help bring the ufc to all these world
markets all over the world.
So everyone's all excited about this.
So then they have this huge event where
it's like a $3 million dollar gate,
okay.
For ticket sales,
they have fucking ferrari world.
They put it inside for our first outside
thing.
The thing looks fantastic.
The crowd is insane.
The crowd was awesome.
They were so pumped up.
Everybody was super fucking rowdy.
Every fight was chaos except the bj
penn,
frankie edgar fight.
That was just very close,
you know,
but there was some wild ass flights
before the black.
Brad,
brad,
brad blackburn and demarcus johnson got
damn kendall grove and Mark Munoz.
That fucking fight was awesome.
It was just not.
The crowd is height to the gills.
Anderson silva comes in,
they go fucking crazy.
The new sunshine.
We're in shoes.
The music plays.
You see him dance dancing.
They're going fucking bananas and he
runs for the last two rounds and dude,
it was a disaster.
Everybody walked out of there with their
head hung,
shaking their head going,
what the fuck?
Everyone was disappointed.
It wasn't like.
There was two arguments.
Some people were saying,
wow,
I see his point.
Why take a chance?
No,
everyone was bummed out what the ufc
cells is just wild shit.
You're selling wild fucking chaos fights
the most exciting sport in the world.
What anderson silva is selling is he's
the very best at the wild shit and
meanwhile he didn't do it the last two
rounds.
He just ran away.
That's terrible for the business.
It's terrible for what the ufc is trying
to accomplish in other countries.
It's terrible for the new partnership
with flash entertainment.
It's terrible.
But have a ufc outside and all the
fighters be added their helmet to it is,
you're right.
But it's even,
they're both out of their element.
Yeah.
But they're also.
I mean,
that's just different,
you know,
that's like one who has fun and he was,
he was fighting though.
It was cool down.
It cooled down to like maybe a
seventies,
but the first guy's.
Yeah,
john madsen and uh,
and staff.
I'll turn those motherfuckers fought in
a sauna.
Which you think about that gracie fight
though.
I,
I thought that was awful.
Well,
hanzo hadn't trained for two and a half
years.
Wow.
That's a long time.
I said it didn't train at all this what
he said in the post fight interview.
And then he,
um,
trained for six months for the fight and
it just wasn't enough.
Matt hughes for him,
he had been looking to knock somebody
out forever.
So for him it was,
it was an awesome opportunity to finally
get someone who's going to stand in
front of them.
Wow.
You know,
like legs and.
Yeah,
he like,
kicked the shit out of them.
I thought it was going to take them
down.
I thought he would beat him from the top
because matthew is,
even though a kenzo has really good
jujitsu,
jujitsu is very underrated and he's just
very,
very strong.
And his wrestling,
I'm like,
okay.
We did the hoist when he got him on the
ground,
he doesn't land through voice when he
got him on the ground.
Yeah,
he's strong as fuck man.
And I just think,
uh,
you know,
it had been more exciting if they went
to the ground now there were both would
have been in their element instead.
It was like a sloppy kickboxing.
He was bad.
Yeah.
It looked like ultimate fighter.
Like the first episode.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like,
like the tv show.
Yeah,
yeah,
it's so much.
They're mean,
they're both doing things they're not
good at.
It's like you and I were going to have a
one on one game of basketball.
Right.
We pulled that.
It's terrible,
you know,
but you know,
if they both had a um,
if they try to take each other down and
you know,
and,
and how to ground battle,
that would have been exciting as fuck
for matthew's notes.
It was a smart move.
He had an advantage standing up and plus
no one's going to take him down.
It's very tough to take that guy.
But you gotta be like gsp to take matt.
He was down so he wasn't gonna take them
down.
And matt,
he's felt like he had an advanced
standing,
so beat him up.
So that's what he did.
He beat him up with leg kicks,
slow them down and then eventually
planted them.
You know,
I think matthew is still has a lot of
fights in them.
If he wants to do,
there's still a lot of good matchup for
him if he really gets motivated.
I don't think he's gonna fight like that
with that many people though.
I think his decision to stand up with
him was purely based on that.
He felt like he had an advantage in that
position.
It needs to change his opening song
already.
I'm done with it.
Oh goddamn class.
Now,
because you said that your mother
fucker.
I'm just saying that you know it's done
with that.
I think my favorite fights are the
japanese do.
That's not fighting anymore of the ufc
because he lost the last one where he
dresses up and he has fun with the
opening.
Like the japanese guy.
He is my favorite man when he's a fuck.
I wish they would.
There's no chance he's ever coming back
to usc.
Right.
I'll really go almost still pretty young
man.
I liked him.
He's one of my kids.
Loves this song.
Motherfucker.
A great goddamn song.
So you never wanted to live in the woods
like this motherfucker.
I liked it the first 500 times I'm
hurting.
I don't give a shit when he comes out to
that bucket to come on.
Son isn't the greatest walkout music
ever,
in my opinion.
There's no better walk out music and
this song.
No better match.
Doesn't,
doesn't.
What's better?
Come on son.
It's perfect for him.
Mix it up a little.
I'm always about mixing it up.
One a million fucking fights with that
song.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
It's grace on it.
Plus the ufc owns outside.
That's perfect.
They bought the rights to.
That's really because of the med schools
so they can use the.
The time.
Yeah,
they're.
The ufc is fucking crazy.
Is there any new kimbo fight versus
montreal?
Um,
may May 9th,
ninth in montreal.
Nice.
Go.
If you want to go.
Yeah.
It gets fucking floor seats to the ufc.
You have all you people out there that
are like,
fuck man,
I would love to go.
You can't even.
No,
that's bullshit.
So,
uh,
I actually prefer it.
Dude.
I'll watching on tv.
Yeah,
you were to tell you.
I bet you would if you were with it.
We go to barney's beanery now.
There will come a time where I will be
watching it on tv.
I'm not going to do this forever.
Yeah,
we go to barney's beanery.
There's a tv at our table,
a plasma right in front of us.
There was like movie theater,
have tvs.
We got waitresses bringing us the joke
for worst food ever beer.
There's like 20 of us.
I mean it's like I'm already.
That's better.
Right?
It's way better.
It is better.
God damn it.
You got to call in sick soon.
I know,
right?
I'm responsible for part of the
entertainment part of it though.
The talking part,
you know,
I would like to.
I like watching it with commentary men.
Oh,
I don't.
I would way rather watch somebody else
do commentary like michael chavela or
like michael chavela and goldberg got
together and then like put a fighter in
there like pat military or something
like that.
I'd be happy as fuck to sit home and
watch that.
You stick it.
Can't do it from your home.
Like you know how like xm radio stations
that they could do their shipping alone
now to many kids just sit there with a
tv and whatnot to interview the
fighters.
Holograms,
man with a monitor.
Real doll.
That's what we like.
What we were talking about before,
that one,
they could replicate people.
The first thing to do is replicate
celebrities so you could fuck them.
Yeah.
So no.
I eventually though I'm just going to
just stand up.
I don't know when it's gonna happen,
but maybe sooner than later I'm,
I'm not.
I don't like all this traveling,
you know?
That's crazy.
That was one of your health.
There's one thing that everyone was
talking about,
the borrow is at,
is that there's too many ufc is now.
Yeah.
They were all talking about that.
Really?
Yeah.
Were like,
that's why we're coming here because I
can't afford to ufc a month.
Meanwhile the paper view numbers are
still.
Yeah,
absolutely.
There always be awesome.
You know,
the point is though,
the more they do it
more grows and the more it becomes a
part of the culture and it's 12 months a
year and it never stops.
I mean it really is.
Gonna take over everything.
It's gonna.
You know,
what's gonna happen eventually?
I'll probably just do the vegas ones
eventually.
Yeah,
just do some of them,
you know,
or the la to la.
They won't come back
very often.
They go to la once a year,
every two years or something like that.
Say we've got too many places to go.
We gotta go to fucking Germany and
Ireland and Australia.
I don't have to be crazy.
Well,
the wec went to Ohio this year.
I know,
but why do you have to go to Afghanistan
and why don't you just go to Ohio
because they want to take over the
world,
you know,
they want to take over the world.
Look,
they have a product that was very,
very undersold when they first came into
the ufc.
The ufc had insane potential but very
little coverage.
Very few people know about it.
When,
when I first started working for the ufc
was in 1997
and that the company that I worked for
was seg,
a much smaller company than the ufc.
Now zuph.
Uh,
it was,
you know,
it was a,
we did a lot of the same guys are still
there.
A lot of the behind the scenes gas.
We did shows in like little fucking high
school auditoriums and like doeth in
Alabama and shit,
like really small ass shows and we
always said,
you know what,
this sport needs this support needs some
fucking crazy billionaires who just
loved the sport to come in there and
just shoving in front of people's faces,
put it on tv,
spend a fuckload of money and make it
huge.
But nobody ever thought that was really
gonna happen.
But that is what happened with zoo fa.
What happened is these guys had owned 22
fucking casinos happened to be ufc fans
and they decided to buy it for fun.
You know,
let's buy the ufc.
That'll be fun.
So they get dana to run it.
I mean,
you'd have to be crazy to get that
fucking guy to run it.
You know what I mean?
Think about that are really intelligent,
but he's the perfect guy.
The perfect,
the perfect guy for it,
but what other corporation would have us
as a president or a ceo like that I
fighting,
there are no other ones.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like you would go,
okay,
what happened?
Businessman who would step in and do it,
and meanwhile I'm dana is just a nut and
a crazy fight.
Phenome.
He's the perfect guy for the job.
Literally,
you couldn't get a better guy for the
job,
but you know,
then they took over.
But they realized when they took over,
once it started taking off,
after the ultimate fighter tv show
started airing,
they realized that all the sport needed
in America was exposure.
And this is a sport that transcends
cultural boundaries,
languages,
it,
it transcends everything.
Traditions.
Everybody understands fighting.
You know,
nobody's going to watch fucking cricket
in America.
You're never going to sell that.
You know,
you can try to make people think they're
sophisticated.
If they enjoy soccer or maybe you know,
your family's from latin America,
so you like soccer,
but no one is going to fucking buy
cricket.
They're not going to buy cricket.
But fighting,
fighting is everywhere you can.
You can watch fighting in China,
you can watch fighting in Germany.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if you understand the
language it.
I'd like watching the old prides when
the,
uh,
I used to get prides straight from Japan
and the commentary would all be in
japanese.
It was fucking awesome.
Yeah.
I didn't even know what that was,
but I will get knocked up,
will go crazy.
Screaming to japanese.
It was fucking awesome.
I didn't have to know what they were
saying.
I love it.
I loved everything about party.
Even the opening walk,
I thought it was great.
I did
pageantry.
How the other giant screens,
the dude's face on it and shit.
I thought that was pretty.
I think it's fun,
man.
It's ridiculous.
They had pyrotechnics for awhile,
but then uh,
uh,
Joe Hill,
de oliveira got burned.
He got barbecued during one of the
pyrotechnics.
Mma tried to do right?
Yeah.
They have like live music bands.
I can't rock with talking about elite.
That was so stupid.
Yeah.
They had a band play a song.
Auto affliction.
Did that affliction.
Affliction?
Yeah.
Of.
Those
silly fox.
They had a band play a song in the
middle of the fucking fight,
like in the mid,
in the middle of the show.
Was he in the middle show?
Were fights,
fights,
go on and then the band play and that's
what it was in the beginning.
I think that's what it was in between
fights or something like that.
So dom and you don't want to mix that.
It's like people have asked me before,
it's like open up for bands,
like do comedy for uh,
you know,
we're gonna have like four bands we'd
like you to go on in the middle.
Do comedy doesn't work like that man.
Nobody wants to see your comedy,
whether in the groove to see music and
nobody wants to see your fucking band.
If they're in the group to see fights,
you know,
it's just like you can't stop a rock
concert,
put on a fight.
You can't do it.
It wouldn't be as good.
You know,
you couldn't have like some fucking
awesome rolling stones concert and then
stop it halfway through the middle and
have like an nma fight.
People will be like,
what is this?
This is bullshit.
What am I following?
You,
you only.
It's,
it's better when you only have one
thing.
One thing is good.
These extravaganzas with adjustable,
I hate doing like award shows to comedy
on award shows because they have like
all these awards and little clips and
then you do standup in the middle of it.
It's like,
oh,
the last time I did that was the guy's
towards the ward for spike.
It was disastrous.
It was terrible.
Nobody wanted to hear anybody's comedy.
It was like the whole thing was like
they were sitting there for three hours,
watch some boring ass award show,
so they wanted to just get the fuck out
of there by the time I got on was.
Did you hear about that?
Conan gail?
Yeah.
He's got to do tvs right before lopez.
That's good for him.
Both of them.
For both of them.
Yeah.
I don't know why.
I think it's good for him too.
It's because they'll let him do whatever
the fuck you want.
Yeah,
exactly.
Ubs is going to blow up,
not blow up and by the way has already
rich.
Right.
He made so much money from that.
Just leaving be,
you know,
I think even like 35 million bucks he
can do whatever the fuck he wants.
Now.
Is tbs the same company as spike?
No,
I don't think so.
I don't know.
Just comedy central is comedy central
and spike or that's why my,
my special first year and I was black
and then are on comedy central.
Um,
and you can get my that dvds available
now.
So go,
go buy the amazon link on your website.
Yeah,
it's on my way on joe rogan.net
and it's on a,
it was the number two on itunes.
I don't know if it still is.
Yeah,
robin williams.
What the fuck's hilarious.
Did you ever go ahead of beto?
I don't know if I ever been,
but god,
how could I don't get that?
I understand how some people think some
things,
some things are funny.
You know,
there's some guys that I get that people
think they're funny,
but I don't see it.
The robin williams thing goes right over
my head.
I just,
I go,
what are you laughing at?
I have never laughed at him once.
Maybe in a movie,
you know,
like whenever,
something like that,
when I was a kid I listened to stand up
because it was raunchy,
like he was talking about this deck and
I was like seven years old watching hbo,
you know,
so that's the only reason I ever liked
him.
He never did it for me.
And then when I heard he was a giant
thief,
then he's forever tainted.
Like even if he says something funny,
I'm watching him.
He says something funny.
I'm like,
where'd you get that from?
Another steal that from you.
Fuck right.
Uh,
so,
uh,
crazy celebrities.
Do you hear about steven seagal?
Steven seagal got arrested.
He did?
Yes.
Impossible.
He's getting,
he's getting.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Just getting sued.
He didn't get arrested.
Andy dick is dick got arrested?
Yeah.
And did you hear about that?
Walked into someone's house?
Well he was also the day before he was
thrown out of a winery in santa barbara
for being too drunk.
How do you get thrown out of a winery?
Dr.
Drew.
You don't.
If you're out there,
I blame you.
Uh,
why do you believe dr to have enabled
dandy dick?
Sir?
He was on sober house with dr drew.
Oh,
that's fine.
I don't know.
It wasn't dr silver house.
Was that it?
I don't think.
Whichever one it is.
What does it?
Celebrity rehab was young.
I had one of them.
He was on celebrity rehab or something.
I dunno,
he's practiced.
Maybe dick.
Maybe.
I'm just imagining how rude dr drew.
We're just kidding.
Just kidding.
Oh,
fucking celebrity rehab is spectacular.
It's one of my favorite shows ever.
If you ever wanted like motivation to
not do drugs.
Watch tom sizemore on.
What about that chick that,
that.
Oh,
annoying was the crazy sex attic check.
I,
I swear to god,
she's one of those girls that,
that they shouldn't even have her on the
show because it's just disgusting to
watch.
She's pretty gross.
I actually liked the.
Ended up liking the girl from that day
was that she used to be on that old
sitcom a that has the dog that died
during the show.
Uh,
that wrote the book about being
molested.
Mackenzie phillips liked her.
She's a nice person.
She seemed cool to her whole store is a
horrible.
Yeah,
it is horrible if you don't have those
stories.
Mackenzie phillips.
Dad fucked her like her whole life.
She had a sexual relationship with her
dad like her whole life and her dad shot
her up with heroin or with cocaine when
she was 11.
Jesus christ.
What a 11.
And her.
Her dad shut her up with coke.
I mean,
the whole thing is just the most
horrific thing you could ever possibly
imagine that someone would do this to
their kid and fuck their kid their whole
life had a sexual relationship with
their kid.
It to the point where she told her like,
hey,
we could leave.
When you go to countries where this is
totally acceptable,
what country is he going to go to?
What country is it acceptable to fuck
your kids?
Is there one out there now that should
be just death?
Jesus christ.
Nice to be death.
Yeah.
Well,
speaking of death,
the catholic religion is fighting to.
They're trying to impose a statute of
limitations on sexual molestation cases
because right now there's a statute of
limitations on sexual molestation cases.
That's like,
I believe it's like 30 years.
So they're trying to impose a,
they're,
they're trying to make sure that that
sticks.
They,
they want to make sure that,
um,
they don't,
they don't change it to no statute of
limitations because then anytime someone
has a case right now,
if a case is more than 30 years old,
I think it's 30 years.
Pretty sure the case is more than 30
years old.
You have to,
if you're going to be a part of a case,
you have to be joining with other people
that are,
that are also inside the case.
So say if someone has a case that's 29
years old and yours is 30 and the same
priest buck to you,
then you can join in.
But if yours is the individual case
there,
they're saying you don't want you to be
able to sue.
And people are saying,
no,
this is crazy.
Crazy.
And meanwhile,
the catholic church is urging people to
vote against this because they're saying
that it's an assault on the church.
How is pedophiles?
How is shielding pedophiles with a
statute of limitations?
How has that fucking helping the church
and how would getting rid of any,
any statute of limitations that would
impose a timeline for when you can be
prosecuted for a horrible crime against
humanity?
How could that be what god wants?
That god wants you to
sick of it.
Joe,
you know,
ridiculous.
Joe.
I was thinking about today.
I just got in a huge fight with my
sister.
I unfaced book or your sister.
Let's talk about.
Well,
you can't talk about it.
I can't,
but I can tell you that I unfaced bucked
her and because I on facebook,
teresa,
she's about to have a baby and she said
that I could no longer be an uncle
because I on facebook,
but there's only two times be an uncle
anymore.
She's not allowing me.
Oh,
let's all stand would be an uncle to my
daughter.
How sure I am.
I'm the uncle,
his uncle.
So anyways,
there was a two times that I've gotten
into such a huge fight with my sister.
Both of these times.
It rooted from religion.
Well,
you know,
I met.
People want to believe that there are
some rules and regulations to the world
because it makes them feel better.
And when you come along and say that
they're not,
that they don't exist,
then it makes them.
We have to reevaluate their whole life
and they fucking hate it and they get
angry at you because you're fucking up
their piece.
You're fucking.
They have developed a piece of mine from
the idea that god is great,
god is good,
and you do the right things.
You're going to go to heaven like that
helps them get through the day,
man.
And for a lot of people it's a nice
simple box to put the world at.
And when you
go fuck,
it's a fucking box look,
fuck.
They want that box back.
Then it makes sense.
So the real problem is when anybody
tells you that they know,
that's when the problem came over.
Game over,
man,
you can't.
You know,
you don't know man.
You're not dead,
you're not in heaven,
you're not an alien,
you're not from the future.
You don't know.
Shut the fuck up.
Don't know.
Fuck it all,
fuck religion,
fuck,
fuck.
Any ideologies,
anybody telling you how you can live
your life.
You know what?
What is good?
When people offer advice and people say,
this is what I've learned from my
mistakes and this is what I've learned
from my life and this could possibly
benefit you if you come across the same
situations.
This is what I've learned.
This has made my life easier.
This made my life better.
I learned to be nicer to people.
I learned to suck it up.
When this happens,
I learned to look in the mirror.
When you
got problems,
I learned to evaluate,
you know,
look at my own life.
Objectively.
Forest are pointed the finger at other
people.
Those are all things that can help you.
When you start talking about,
you know,
you kind of have pork and I love this
number.
Here's a photo of mohammed is available.
Well,
you must miss that guy keeps on getting
threatened.
He don't.
He almost got killed,
murdered the other day.
The guy that,
the cartoonist that drew mohammed the
other day,
he almost got like,
it was like last week or something like
that.
People have been killed for that.
People have been killed for drawing.
Muhammad.
Why is trey parker and matt stone not
dead yet?
They drama humble.
They had a whole episode about muhammad.
That's a good question.
This guy just had a stupid family circus
comic when I went over to,
uh,
abu dhabi.
I was thinking,
I hope none of these motherfuckers have
a copy of shiny happy gi.
No sticking.
I us thinking that dude my fucking seat,
my last cd,
not this one,
but the one before that was called shiny
happy jihad.
Or they probably know that I have a copy
of it.
I'm going to start giving them away
because I just got a box of them.
Right.
Did your one cd is out of print?
I still think the idea of.
I had an idea.
He has this odd cdd,
can't do it.
Remixes,
remixes,
remix the bits into like,
you know,
because they're kids,
but they're gone.
They got to go,
I need a new sheriff in town,
but this is,
this was what I was worried.
If you don't not familiar with any of my
comedy,
it's fucking,
it's called shiny happy jihad.
And it's me.
Can you see that was the just.
There we go.
It's me with fucking dmt and it says g
on it.
I mean,
that's probably one of my best cds.
I think it's my favorite.
Uh,
the last one is really good too.
The last one's a little heavier.
This one's a little sillier,
but I don't know.
That's one of my favorites.
But I was like,
god,
I hope none of these motherfuckers have
this because like half of the bits are
about suicide bombing and fucking making
fun of osama bin ladin living in a cave.
I mean,
it's a lot of,
a lot of them.
Gee,
there's a lot of that in there.
Some guy remix that jihad and made a
terrible song out of it.
I still think you need to work on your
new song that you wrote in tempe.
I think that's a great song that he has
a song.
That's.
Where was the Arizona?
That was number one.
Girls.
Oh,
that song,
that song?
Yeah,
that's what I was really popular.
But panini was like number one for like.
Yeah,
it was number one for like a couple of
months because these guys,
tim and mark in,
uh,
in phoenix.
I love this guys there.
They don't work there anymore.
Unfortunately.
If they got fired up,
you probably don't know them.
You're thinking of something that,
you know,
the ones that we filmed the original a
dvd for like three years ago,
four years ago.
Would they then.
Yeah,
I filmed something for later.
Well anyway,
these guys,
they started playing it.
It's this cycle about pussy by booty
pussy.
It's called nanny.
But you can play
it on the radio.
It's like,
it's pretty clean.
It's all about any guy knows what this
is all about.
Like there are,
there are girls' vaginas are not created
equal.
They're just not,
you know.
And,
and sex is not equal either.
You,
you could have sex with one person and
it's boring as fuck.
And then you can have sex with another
chick and she's just a goddamn freak.
And every now and then you'll come
across a girl who's a freak and she's
got a super pussy and there are pussies.
They're super pussies.
Yeah.
Where you,
you get into any like god damn.
There was this one girl that I used to
fuck and literally her,
her pussy was like,
it was like velvet.
There was something going on in there.
It was like,
it just gripped your dick.
It was,
she wasn't a small girl.
She was tall,
but her pussy was super tight and always
wet.
And it was.
And she was a,
just a total pervert,
just a freak.
And literally it was like a drug.
And I see,
I used to call it voodoo pussy.
I'm like,
this page has got food pussy.
So I had to write a song about udo
pussy.
So I wrote the song voodoo nanny,
which is one my 1999 and cd,
which is called a.
I'm going to be dead someday.
So,
um,
you know,
I've thought about writing another song.
I might write something else if I found
something.
I like the new one,
the new one that you knew.
It was pretty funny.
Girl's butthole were high one night.
I just started singing that and they got
stuck in everybody's head and all night
we were just walking around going to
assume senior girl's butthole.
I can't tell you what the subjects.
Why this came up is this dude that we
know was dating this girl that does some
things where you might be able to see
her butthole,
like the whole world can see it.
It's funny.
So I like that guy now.
He's a good guy.
He's a good dude.
I like that.
Dude.
So you've been using your high tab a,
what's it called?
Ipad a lot later.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
How has the battery life did you use it?
Dominoes
the whole way.
I didn't charge it once.
I charged it right before I left,
but I was reading like with it every
day,
like reading in bed and uh,
I was a watch.
I was surfing the web on it.
I was doing all sorts of shit on it.
Man.
I have a review I just did and I showed
this new application that lets you take
your iphone and it bluetooths connects
it to your ipad.
It's like a wireless webcam.
I saw that,
but that's just like a shitty
programming.
Can you imagine if apple releases a.
Here's what.
Here's my.
Here's my rumor what I think it's going
to be.
I just made this up last night.
All right,
so they have the new iphone that comes
out in june.
They're going to next.
There's all this room are going to have
a front facing camera with it chat so
you can do I chat live video on your
phone.
So what?
I think they're waiting for that rumor
and they're going to release a bluetooth
hd camera that will snap on top of your
eye tab and do the same thing.
So you can have like a little wireless
camera.
Why don't they just have a camera built
this saturday?
Well I have to hit some bluetooth thing
that's gay because in the bluetooth
going to run out of batteries and how's
it going?
I'm going to have to charge it.
That's.
Well,
there should be an iphone camera.
Why don't you make a camera in there?
I think they're going to happen.
I think it's going to be like a $300
camera.
I think it's gonna be like hd,
like high quality.
Just making this up.
Well,
I am not going to sell it.
This is definitely those.
Jesus,
this is going to go back in time.
Can go back in time with that and it'll
suck your dick while you take a.
That was awesome.
That program alone just kind of made me
go,
you know what?
Something like this is coming.
That's what's gonna happen.
Eventually,
eventually it's going to be like a
portal to another dimension.
There'll be a mouth on the other
dimension.
You get a hard on and you put the ipad
and your dick goes right through the
ipad to someone's mouth.
Another know in another dimension to
pull your ipad out.
What if it crashes?
Halfway through dick is stuck in the
fucking 11,
just floating around with it.
Special episode of oprah winfrey.
Gods who lost half their dick into
another dimension.
Maybe one dude is like,
I only lost the tip.
I was just about to put it in.
We had a power outage.
It was just about,
I guess it was some sort of a solar
flare and so now,
I mean had the top of my degree
is flat.
It's kind of a novelty goes into like a
beer can.
He doesn't have a head.
It doesn't have a curve to it.
Just think flat.
Yeah.
Who knows what the fuck is coming up
next man.
There's gonna be some crazy shit though.
It's gonna.
Keep going.
They're going to keep inventing more and
more nutty shit and like I said before,
I think that it's all it.
Everything has to do with connectivity.
Everything has to do with bringing
people closer and closer together.
That's what this whole tiger woods thing
is all about.
That this would not have happened 30,
40 years ago because there wouldn't be
the kind of connectivity that people
have now with the internet.
The internet keeps.
It's getting worse and worse.
Man,
did you hear what else has came out the
other day that a fucking oprah winfrey.
Oprah winfrey?
Yeah,
it's Jesse James.
It's going to consist jim carrey,
a good a whole article on this whole
thing on gizmodo or mondo or whatever
it's called,
dot com.
Moan about celebrities ruined.
Enter careers from twitter and all that
stuff because there's too much
information is getting out and you know,
it's crazy.
That is a good point because a lot of
celebrities,
really the illusion is way better than
who they are.
Oh yeah.
You know,
you get to know them.
like it's.
It is a trick,
you know,
most other sports in niggers,
a trick obviously you know how few
actors would ever want to do something
like this.
Fuck if they did that because look,
look at us.
There's no makeup.
We're just fucking hanging on my office.
Look,
I'm a fucking slob.
That's all my shit.
I'm cleaning out my office.
This is my,
my new desk is behind me.
I bought this fucking desk a year ago
and I still have not set it up yet.
The desk did.
Everything's on right now is too big,
so this desk,
I'm getting rid of a moving that desk in
the place and that wall is going to be a
green screen.
I always buy things and it's always in
plastics.
You have so many things that you've
never even know.
Well,
I am what,
what you would be like if you were 12
years old and all of a sudden you had
money to.
Somebody just gave you free money.
Just buy stupid shit.
But this,
I have this because um,
I think that,
um,
I think a lot of things up in my car and
I don't want to be fiddling around.
I just want to push a button so I got a
digital recorder when I drive,
I come up.
Do you drive?
You come up with ideas where you drive?
Yeah,
I do.
But you know what's funny is I,
we talked about this last week to the
point where like I have to get my words
out as quick as possible.
It happened to me like two days after
that I had thought of this hilarious
thing about metallica.
Pete,
we're talking about metallica and I'm
like,
oh,
I get my iphone out,
got my iphone out,
and somebody says,
hey brian.
I'm like,
oh hey,
fuck.
Lost it.
You don't even remember what it is.
I've been trying to think about it all
time.
Was so fucking funny though.
I can't even remember it.
Yeah,
it's when someone's talking to you and
you have an idea,
you can totally lose it.
Like I'll get ideas.
Awesome.
I will cover my ears and run away from
like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
Man?
You're fucking rude.
Then I have to come back and explain to
them I'm so sorry.
I had an idea and it was super
important.
But for me any idea like that is like,
those are diamonds.
Like there's ideas that have come up
with like,
you know,
that became bits,
that those pits are so valuable to me,
you know,
like,
like my Anna Nicole Smith bed or
something like that.
Like some of the classic bits that I had
in the past.
What if,
as I was thinking that up,
somebody came up to me and started
talking about their stupid bullshit,
right?
Because some people are fucking brutal
and they don't take the hint ever.
Like they just want to say what they
have to say to you.
You can't say,
can you hold on,
hold on a second.
They'll just keep talking.
Hold on a second dude,
stop.
Fuck,
fuck.
And then I was watching the ufc next to
a guidance.
I just met with a friend of a friend,
but the whole fight,
he sounded like a reporter from the 19
twenties talking to dick tracy.
It's like that.
Anything about that yet.
So when you think about that,
I'm like,
even talk like that.
He's,
that's funny thing about his legs.
I think as long as I can.
And I'm just like,
oh,
shut the fuck.
We're like,
I hate when people don't have that
quality of self evaluated.
You know what I mean?
That just drives me crazy when I meet
somebody that does.
How important is that?
Uh,
we know a lot of people that don't have
that quality.
We know a lot of people,
most people don't have that quality.
It's a bad quality,
but in the usually the people at this is
another thing that people don't have
that quality are usually not successful
and it's one of the reasons why they're
not successful is there.
There's a.
There's a disconnect between them and
other people.
Other people do not see them the way
everybody else does or them the way
rather they see themselves,
they see themselves like completely
distorted and that's why they haven't
been successful.
They're not being objective because
objectivity requires pain.
You know?
No one's perfect.
Okay.
Especially when you're younger,
if you're not making mistakes,
you're not trying.
If you're not trying,
you're not going to get better at
anything you do.
You're gonna fuck up.
You're going to make horrible mistakes.
I mean,
one of the reasons I got good at standup
is because being bad at standup is so
fucking painful,
you know,
and the only way you got to find that
out by getting in front of people and
having them hate you,
having them not laugh and believe,
well a lot of people don't have an
audience in their life.
They don't have anything to evaluate
themselves with so they don't evaluate
themselves.
So they have this distorted perception
of how cool you are.
That's with guys and drinking.
That's the most painful.
The mouse drinking.
Yeah.
It's your worst.
And I've been,
I,
I made it,
I've done it before,
but I've also like the next day slapped
my forehead going,
okay,
next time I drink I got to remember that
I do that.
I need,
you know,
I've.
But there's some people,
it's supposed to guys get really close
in your face when they're drunk.
Some dude did that in and other job and
he kept telling me that he was some
prince's cousin and this and that.
And then men,
you come with me,
all the bitches,
man.
Come on,
We're going to do business together,
you know,
it was you and I are going to open up.
I like to get the fuck away from me.
You're,
you're spitting in my ear,
man,
and telling me how we're going to go
into business together in dubai and like
get the fuck out of here man.
We're not going into business together.
It's chicken.
My Mike Young used to do a joke about
that was one of my favorite bits about
how everybody does coke wants to open up
a business with you because it's totally
true.
When dudes do coke,
they always have business plans because
they have all kinds of plants.
All kinds of,
oh,
coke is the worst drug in the world.
Is the worst drugs ever been created?
It is the number one retailer drug.
There's no better when you're out and
you're surrounded by a bunch of coke
cans and they're just talking out.
Know the worst is when you're high and
they're cooked up.
Is there ever a worse combination?
There's no worse combination.
Then when you're stoned and you're
hanging around coke heads because stone
is like you're timid and you're humble.
You know,
when you,
when you smoke pot,
you all,
you start realizing like,
god,
I'm like this fleshy little thing.
You know,
like if there's a line in this room,
that line can just eat me.
There's nothing I can do about it.
When you're coked up,
you never think about a lion.
If you do like a little fucking line to
that line of something like grade math
is the worst somebody put on there also.
Yeah,
I agree with math.
I wonder how many people.
Yeah,
robin williams was a coke addict.
I wonder how many people,
um,
but that I've been around have been on
methadone.
I didn't know it.
I bet a lot.
La man,
there's a lot.
Half the people that we think are
fucking crazy or just on math.
A lot of people
are messed up,
man.
That is definitely true.
A lot of people that are like,
when you see people that are real skinny
and drawn out and they're fucking
talking wacky.
It's something.
What is it?
It's some sort of amphetamines,
whether it's math or do you know that
meth was invented during world war one
and world war two,
the japanese used it for the,
um,
for suicide bombers.
That's how they talked to kamikaze.
He's into fucking crashing planes into
boats.
Yeah,
they would.
They would hook them up with meth.
Nice.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Not only the government is not only
experimented with that.
I mean they've done.
The japanese government gave them
amphetamines and crystal meth and shit
like that.
But I'm also steroids.
The United States government has done
that in the past.
Like soldiers have told,
been told that they have to take certain
pills,
you have to take things.
And when you take them finance,
like anna bar,
which is an oral steroid,
super hyper
aggressive,
which totally makes sense.
Yeah.
And when guys are juiced up,
if guys were all juiced out there
fucking,
they feel like they're invincible.
You're,
your body's all flooded with
testosterone.
Like gorillas must feel completely
invincible.
You know,
when you're just fucking,
you know,
you're living in the woods,
you're covered in hair,
you weigh 800 pounds.
They don't worry about shit.
Take a totally beat a fighter by the
way.
Gorilla is versus a person.
Oh,
crusher person.
No,
I mean a person who would be the gorilla
beat eddie.
Eddie was trying to make some crazy
argument that it was people that could
be the champion.
A fight.
I'm like,
what the fuck it ship would just bite
your fingers off.
That's the first thing he would do.
Now try fighting stupid.
Oh,
you're punching him in the head.
Good.
He's grabbing it and eating your
fingers.
So once you all have your fingers are
gone,
then he's going to look at you and go,
now what?
Bitch?
Now I'm going to eat your asshole and
it'll dive onto your asshole.
It was.
Wait till it gets close to your bundle
and you'll be fighting them off where he
get.
Keep getting in there.
I thought eddie was joking the whole
time,
but I don't think he was drunk.
Not drunk at ease.
You know?
Drunk getting drunk.
Drunk.
He was drunk.
Yeah.
Sees three drinks and three drinks and
this drunk eddie.
What?
Support that Jack Daniels.
The lights went out in Georgia,
fucking drum started playing.
The indian came out.
So what brock would destroy gorilla.
Could you imagine what a girl would do
to progress?
You know,
just come charging across.
I'm just.
He knows he can't fucking be extra long.
You ever seen a gorilla Russia person?
It's so goddamn terrifying.
They rush you and they hope that you're
just going to back off and get away and
they just want to claim your territory,
but if you do turn and run,
they might just freak out.
Just chase you and beat the fuck out of
you so you have to turn away and yet,
but you have to stand down,
but you can't look like prey to chimps,
chimps and gorillas and we there are so
strong we couldn't even imagine.
You couldn't even wrap your head around
what they could do to you.
They could literally grab you by the arm
and throw you throw you.
They would pull your arm literally right
off your body like no problem.
A pit bull and killed those people.
Hippo.
That's a dog.
You remember frank have frank.
I always used to think that if this dog
wanted to,
he could kill me.
He could kill anything.
Fucking 90 pound pit bull with his big
fire hydrant head.
If he wanted to,
he would kill me.
You know,
he doesn't know that.
That's why,
you know,
I have no food.
That's why I like being around animals
that can't kill me.
Make an only love.
Yeah.
Like little kitty cat,
kitty cats.
So what do you think about the steven
seagal?
Thanks.
Steven seagal.
Got arrested or didn't get arrested?
He's getting sued.
Let's find a story right here.
Because what happened was apparently he
had some chick that was working for him
and she was his.
She was his,
um,
he's sued for trafficking women and
sexual assault trafficking women.
The woman was a former model and she was
hired the actor
as his executive assistant last
february.
This was on tmz.
So you know,
it's real.
Mr.
Seagal had been keeping to young female
russian attendance on staff who were
available for his sexual desires 24
hours a day,
seven days a week.
So apparently one of the assistants quit
and seagal apparently only roles with
threesomes.
So he made his uh,
he made his assistant,
starts laughing.
He's like,
I need more than one.
He had two hookers that were working for
him.
Twenty four slash seven and one of them
probably met some rich dude somewhere
and got a better job.
Fuck a cigar.
That much money tv show now.
Yeah.
But that's not shit.
He's done a lot of,
oh,
he's making money off that show.
It makes the star.
I guarantee you it makes a few hundred
thousand dollars a year for sure off
that show.
Maybe half a million,
maybe more because he's a big star.
He might make a million a year off that
show.
They might've given them a big deal.
It might make more than a million a
year.
So he's got that.
Okay.
Then he's got.
How many movies did he do?
He did a lot of goddamn movie.
So you got divorced in 1996.
So everything from 1996 until now.
It's all his money.
I bet he's got a lot of money.
I bet he's got a ton of money.
It's money doesn't seem smart with his
money.
It seems like it's spinosa money on
ponytail,
juice,
juice.
What does that even mean?
Conditioner.
How much has conditioner and he's got
good conditioning.
He's um,
I mean he's,
he's still a big star in those foreign
movies,
like straight to video,
dvd sales because he could still sell a
steven seagal movie,
you know,
you make it for cheap money and you sell
it fairly cheap and they,
you know,
the air it on cable at 3:00
in the morning and they sell them on
dvds.
There's still some money in that.
But like when I said was when I was in
a,
uh,
abu dhabi,
when you go to dubai,
dubai's flooded with hookers and there's
hookers,
airways,
russian hookers.
So apparently there's a lot of them.
So it's not outside the realm of
possibility that some actor,
we just hired two of them like to be on
call 24 slash seven.
Right.
I think it's,
I mean,
look,
if that's how you want to roll,
I think that's a pimp move.
I mean,
the dude's not even fucking married,
right?
You use,
you can't really criticize it.
I mean,
you can criticize the fact that he's a,
you know,
he's hiring prostitutes,
but let's be honest,
what the fuck is,
you know,
a lot of rich guys,
wives,
what,
what are they,
you know,
are they really attracted to them?
Is,
I mean,
it's tiger woods wife.
Does she really think he's hot,
you know,
or do you think he's hot because he's
rich?
You know,
how many of them think he's hot because
he's rich?
How many super goofy looking dudes that
are multibillionaires who have these
model wives.
He's super fucking hot wise.
What's going on there?
You know,
Donald Trump,
you ever see donald trump's wife hot as
fuck.
Yeah,
he's a powerful man and all that good
stuff and they're attracted to that and
security and all that good stuff.
But at the end of the day,
he is rich.
They're hot,
he's ugly.
What's going on there?
I mean,
this is a form of prostitution,
right?
It really is.
Yeah.
I mean,
what's the sexual prostitution is the
whole difference?
Is that in sexual prostitution?
So apparently,
you know,
the idea is that it's not good because
there's no love,
there's no real emotions,
no relationship,
you know,
it's just sex for money.
But like what if you like data girl and
you actually enjoy her company and need
your time and you like her and you say,
listen,
you have a shitty job and I have a lot
of money.
How about you quit your job and I pay
you a thousand dollars a week and this
is what you have to do.
You just have to suck my dick anytime I
want.
I mean,
you already liked to do it anyway,
right?
Well let's just make it sort of a job.
Okay.
And you'll get a check every week.
But I don't wanna hear any argument from
me.
I think that'd be cool for like a year.
But I think after that,
I don't know,
man,
it's just,
I,
I can see myself doing that if I had a
lot of money.
But women would think that it's
demoralizing and it would be the exact
opposite of a,
you know,
why?
Uh,
why pay for the cow when the milk is
free?
Right will be the exact opposite.
It would be like,
look,
I know I'm getting free melt,
but I would rather pay for the cow and
have that fucking cow.
Give me anytime I want with no argument.
I don't want to get up at four in the
morning.
Go to milk you when you start
complaining.
Listen,
I'm going to pay you right now.
And this is what happens with our
relationship now is we're still friends.
I still love you were boyfriend,
girlfriend,
but I do whatever I want and you suck my
dick whenever asked.
Now you got the bank.
Does that process but yeah.
That.
Is that illegal?
No.
I would say it's illegal,
but I would say that's not illegal.
If you say it is it,
is it on your tax forms?
I'm,
you know,
brian reichles paid hooker.
You,
you go to jail.
Yeah,
that's illegal.
Yeah.
Say if you had a check to do it right,
you know,
you'd have to write it down.
Mean look if you had a girl and she was
a multimillionaire and say if you were a
carpenter.
Okay.
And uh,
you know,
this is your,
you,
you've met her and you used to do some
shit around her house when you first
started dating her and you know,
you do a little carpentry here and
there,
but he did it for free because you loved
her.
And then all of a sudden she said,
listen,
you don't like your job.
Why don't you just come from me,
work for me.
You'll be my carpenter and you just do
whatever I want to do whenever you want.
But the only difference is now a pay
you.
What is the difference between that and
sucking your dick is very,
very little difference,
right?
If you have a chance and she's working
for you and she just gets paid to blow
you,
but she used to blow you for free.
But now she blows you because it's her
job because you pair,
right?
Is that bad?
No.
Especially if you make it.
Let her just let her make her dress up
an outfit.
The old girl only giving my only whore.
You.
I only have one.
It's only you and I don't fucking the
other girl.
I would hate,
I would hate that.
hate,
I,
you know,
because I think the purpose,
my purpose was always finding somebody
that would want to fuck me that much
without any questions asked in that I
would want to fuck that first that I
didn't give you.
This chick likes my logic eve pull.
She likes the logic.
That's a dude.
Sexuality has been immoral.
Uh,
yeah.
It might be a dude,
right?
Sexual has been a more or less,
you know,
I went to whack off last night.
I'm like this hand smiling.
It was like a 2:00
in the morning.
My wife is super pregnant right now and
I can't fuck her on her belly.
I mean,
I do if she asks,
but I,
I don't,
I don't want to impose myself on her.
I felt rude.
I mean she's all pregnant like she's
ready to pop.
And um,
so anyway,
I'm making excuses for why beat off,
beat off.
But that's the reality of it.
I really do feel bad anyway.
I go online to go,
whoa,
look at some porn and everything on one
of my favorite sites is all fucking
spitting in the mouth and gagging and
girls getting their faces fucked with
it,
like halfway throw it up and ate that.
Tears are coming out of their eyes and
the guy smack it on the face with his
dick and he said,
you look like.
And he's like,
fucking like spit and slobber she's
coughing and spits,
coming out.
And I'm like,
okay,
I don't like this,
this is not fun.
And then in the same,
uh,
the same series,
like there was another girl or the same
girl rather than have like a bunch of
videos by this girl named sasha gray,
who was the girl,
another one.
These guys are just violently fucking
her ass.
And then shoving it in her mouth and
finally fucking around and I'm looking
at this and I'm like,
what is going on?
Like,
who is liking all this?
Like mad dog porn?
It's like you've got a mad dog bitches
in porn now.
Nobody just fucks anymore.
It used to be,
you know,
a guy who orders a pizza and the chick
shows up delivering the pizza.
She needs to get changed.
Hate that.
She drops a dollar and she picks it up
and the guy says nice and the girl says,
you think so?
We see the whole thing and then she
pulls her pants down.
Next thing you know their bone and
that's the good old days.
That's fun.
That's good times.
What does this mouth fucking tears
rolling down people's face?
Spitting in people's mouths to dixon
assholes.
Like what's hilarious is that I've never
seen a porn website where it's just like
it's people making love,
just being patched in it and stuff like
that.
Yeah,
there's no.
There's no teasing.
Just fuck my ass.
One girl guys fucking her asshole.
One guy was on top.
He was squatting on top and the other
guy was laying on his back and his dick
was in and the other guy was in and it's
like that joke that I say about like,
you're not even having sex with a woman
at that point,
you're just using her vagina as a
container so that you could rub dicks.
That is really what they were doing.
They were like,
they're two dicks to her.
Her butthole was a holder for dick's.
Dick's while the plowing this girl's
asshole.
I mean,
think about to dick's,
even like two average sized dicks that's
stretching your butthole out till like
that big.
That's ridiculous.
Who wants to see them once and then the
other guy spit in her mouth and they're
fucking her mouth.
I'm like,
jesus,
sasha.
Greg,
get smacked in the face a lot too,
just
because I'm done with all that kind of
thing.
I just like.
I like homemade stuff.
I think we've talked about this.
You liked thinking that that's really
you and this girl is really blowing
real.
Like I want to see people having real
sexy,
really attracted to it.
They're having real orgasms.
They're,
you know,
there's really moaning because they're
moaning,
not definitely something to that man.
It's painful
or you know,
paint like,
and you know,
apparently the porn business is rough
now because of the fact that all this
shit's online.
It's very difficult to,
to like get money for porn.
So these girls get tricked.
It's just like,
you know,
how you hear about the,
uh,
the workers in dubai where they entice
them to come to dubai by saying you're
going to get all this money,
you know,
they take them from India and third
world countries and they basically say
you are going to make x amount of
dollars per month,
you'll be able to send money back home
to your family.
Everybody's going to be happy.
We just,
uh,
you know,
just get,
come out here and you go get a passport
and pay for this and pay for that.
So they do all this.
They get out there and then once they
get out there,
they take their passport and they give
them a fraction of the money these girls
do is they recruit.
These girls will say,
listen,
it's just gonna be you.
And the guy,
you'll get to pick the guy,
it'll be so hot,
no big deal,
no one's going to see it pay you 1500
bucks.
And for a chick who's fucking broken,
desperate and probably,
you know,
not the best thinker in the world
anyway,
I'm not making the best decisions with
their life,
you know.
And some guy offers are 1500 bucks to
fuck some cute guy.
She's like,
whatever.
All right,
I'll do it.
Fuck it.
Who cares?
Who's going to know?
Who's going to know she figures.
I'm just going to go there.
I'm going to take care of to keep them
from repossessed my car.
I'm going to,
you know,
pay my rent off,
and I'll have a couple hundred bucks
left over.
Alright,
let's do it.
So she gets there and there was a whole
series about this on television that
they made her do double anal.
Once she got there,
they said,
no,
we don't want regular sex like this is.
This is what happens to guys who have to
fuck your ass hole and we'll give you
1500 bucks.
Otherwise we don't have work for you.
No condom,
you know,
so she was getting hiv
I.
Yeah.
So she does one
film.
She comes from like Nebraska.
She does one film.
They make her do double anal fucking
pigs nut inside her asshole who probably
fucked 100 chicks that day,
you know?
Yeah.
And they give her hiv.
They're probably shooting heroin up in
the bathroom together.
So I'll get each other's cocks to get
them hard and they stuffed it in her
asshole.
By the way,
I wanted to mention something you talked
about last week in your secret podcast
that I wanted to tell you that no,
brokeback mountain was a huge success.
Yeah.
I think as a comedy,
right?
No,
no.
I mean moneywise.
Yeah,
but as a comedy.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I'd say.
I know people enjoyed it now.
There was a lot of people.
It was sad.
I'll be honest.
At the end of brokeback mountain,
when the guy found out the other guy was
beaten to death,
it was sad.
I never saw it.
I will never watch that.
You want them while it's just watch it
and video put like little kittens over
there
faces when they're kissing,
just like you always do.
There's some shit that I won't watch,
but I won't watch anymore.
Beheadings there's a new line.
Have you seen the new one?
I watched it for a second and they
started cutting the dude's head off.
I said,
all right.
What
the fuck am I doing?
Why am I watching this?
I'm done with that.
Yeah.
There's,
there's no need to be watching that
shit.
I never even watched it.
Uh,
Iraq shooting thing either.
Oh,
that's the other thing.
I wanted to talk about this fake kung
fu.
Yeah.
You need a rack shooting.
Now you need to bring that back.
Then I need to write it out with what I
need to do.
I don't even remember how I did it.
I'll just redo it.
But uh,
the um,
uh,
the Iraq shooting thing,
he didn't want us.
The,
I don't want to do.
We're just talking about collateral
murder,
which is.
We talked about this before.
It was a date mistakenly thought that
these reporters and civilians in Iraq
were insurgents and they killed them and
saw gun camera footage and it's very
disturbing.
It's disturbing how much they were into
it.
It's disturbing how easy it is to just
think that anybody is your enemy when
you're over there and the fucking war
and the chaos,
you know,
it's,
it's scary shit,
man.
It's scary shit that were there in the
first place,
but it's really scary shit to think that
people could just be walking with
cameras and they mistake those cameras
for guns just from the sky with apache
helicopters.
Just fucking light them up with 50
cannon.
I'm done.
The caliber gun.
I'm done with that shit and anything
that's based off three men and a baby,
like three guys in a hammer in India.
This was based on the baby.
Two girls and a cup cup.
Yeah,
no,
you're right man.
You know
the problem is the internet really can
not only desensitize you,
but really change your world.
There's 300 million fucking people in
this country that is an insane amount of
people and if you think about like every
story that you hear about some priest
who's fucking kids or some serial killer
who's killing women or they're all
horrible and terrible,
but the reality is most people are
pretty cool.
There's $300 million of us.
There's so much information that
literally you find out every single
fucking story anytime that they think
goes down.
That's never been the case in the 19
fifties.
You had to be ed gain.
You gotta be,
you know,
wearing women as fucking dresses.
You have to be cutting them up and put
in their skin on.
They had a fight.
You have to make the front fucking page
of the New York times,
like everyday for a week for everyone to
know who you are and everyone would know
your story.
The ted bundy case,
that's another example.
The night stalker,
when he couldn't catch this guy and they
don't know what he's doing,
the zodiac killer,
they never caught them.
Those stories.
That's the only way those stories became
who they had to be so catastrophic
really fucked up,
but now we hear about all of them.
We hear about every two teachers this
week got arrested for fucking kids.
Two teachers,
two different teachers,
both decent looking checks.
One of them was fucking a 16 year old.
She got arrested for a 16 year old.
How the fuck can you arrested?
Check for fucking a 16 year old.
Did you mention it happened to me
though?
You know,
when I was a kid,
a three of our teachers had sex.
One was a guy and two were girls.
When I was in high school,
my spanish teacher fucked one of my
friends.
Yeah,
a female friend of mine.
You know what the funniest thing is?
I remember my science teacher,
sixth grade,
I had my book underneath my desk.
I was reading the book while she was
teaching and she,
brian,
you have two heads.
Only one can read,
and I'm like,
huh,
okay.
Well,
whatever that means,
but then now I look back at it.
I'm like,
oh my god.
She's talking about my head like I'm in
sixth grade.
What the fuck is that?
Crazy.
Ms dot singleton,
columbus,
Ohio.
Fucking what are,
what are you were 12.
How old were you then?
Twelfth grade 12,
right?
Miss singleton and then mr philips,
you were my gym teacher.
You fucked half my friends.
Really?
Yeah.
And he got a resident gym teacher fucked
half your friends are girls mostly boys.
And then,
and then moving,
moving closer.
And then what was weird about it?
Wait,
I'm going to tell the whole goddamn
story from springer in elementary.
Mr philips and he's in jail.
Uh,
no,
check this out.
He was.
Everyone was always talking about it in
elementary school.
Like,
oh don't let Mr.
Phillips,
you know,
get near you.
He fucked so and so.
He fucked so and so before he even got
caught this before.
And there was times where like,
he would come up behind you next
spanking on the button like,
oh,
you just touched on.
So he was fucking a bunch of kids before
he ever got me all knew about it and he
never got caught.
And then one day he got caught and then
we and then there was this one kid that
we thought it was like the one at
squealed or something like that,
and then he was just gone.
He was gone and it was so weird.
It's like a,
I don't know,
like five years later I was working at
toys r us and he came in with like a
whole family and you're just wanting to
say,
hey,
you fucked my friends.
What's up Mr.
Phillips.
He came into toys r us with his family,
with his family,
kids and family.
And I just wanted it to be like,
hey,
you know your husband.
How did he not go to jail?
I don't know what ever happened.
Like I barely remember seeing it in the
papers and stuff like that.
Gotta even if you went to jail,
he got out.
Yeah.
And he.
So he fucked.
How many kids do you think?
I would say there was three that I
thought for sure.
Three that you thought for sure.
I don't want to stay there.
And everybody talks about it.
Oh yeah.
All of us knew about it.
It was like a joke growing up.
Even we would like other teachers knew
like the word that we call him mr.
Film,
fill me up.
Phillips know side,
brookside,
elementary school.
Elementary school I remember was like
fifth grade,
maybe sixth grade,
11,
10.
So that your teacher was fucking 10 boys
in the app and then we had a study hall.
My god,
we had a study hall monitor named Mrs.
Hughes that used to just fuck everybody
too.
But she was hot.
She was and I was like,
oh,
I was mad because I wouldn't fuck.
How old was the middle school was like
eighth grade.
Seventh grade.
She was fucking eighth grade.
Yeah.
And I remember I was pissed because I
was jealous of the other guys who I
fucked her and I'm like,
I want to fuck that girl saving up my
lunch money and stuff.
It's really funny how that works,
isn't it?
You know,
like,
like before the internet man,
shit like that would happen and nobody
would hear about it.
You know?
It had to be like they could,
they could fire the person and stopped
the scandal before it ever hit the
school and no big deal.
Nowadays,
people just throw it up in their face
face.
Fuck you.
I got fucked in the ass.
But I,
Mr.
Phillips,
he's a photo and video.
Oh yeah.
Video and photo.
While it's happening.
If someone's crazy enough to let you
know for a teacher who's crazy enough to
fuck you,
she's crazy enough to film it while
she's fucking crazy.
I'm 35 person asking,
oh yeah,
that's a,
that's a crazy goddamn story.
I didn't.
Um,
I never got molested by kid,
but I came close twice on two separate
occasions.
I almost got molested one when I was
eight years old.
I was at the library and I used to like
a monster books.
I used to like reading like dracula and
frankenstein shit.
And so I'm in this library section and
I'm reading all these books.
I'm looking,
looking for these books and this guy
says,
do you like books on monsters?
And I said,
yeah,
that's my favorite.
I'm like,
you're fucking eight years old,
right?
I don't know that there's bad people
yet.
I haven't really figured that out.
And the guy says,
I've got a bunch of monster books out in
my car.
Oh no.
And I said,
wow,
really?
He goes,
yeah,
come on with me.
I'll show you some monster books.
I go,
oh,
okay.
That's why he had monsters.
I started leaving.
Still love monster movies,
man.
I start leaving and as I'm walking out
the door with this guy,
the fucking librarians starts screaming.
She goes,
joseph,
you get older because she knew me
because I'd go to the library all the
time.
She's like,
joseph,
get over here.
Get over here.
That man just got out of jail,
and so the guy who runs the guy who
wants to go,
she goes,
I'm going to call the police,
and so I run over to the library and I'm
fucking crying and freaking out.
The crazy thing is my mom doesn't even
remember this.
Yeah.
My mom is kind of a knucklehead and when
it comes to that,
like my childhood,
like I can't believe she doesn't
remember this.
Remember that.
Not remember the most horrific moment of
my childhood.
Well,
I feel like if that light.
Brian wasn't there at that moment,
if I didn't have a relationship with her
where I talked to her every time I was
there and she looked after me because
she was a nice lady.
If that didn't happen,
if there was,
she was some absent minded person or
just wasn't looking or didn't know,
didn't know who I was with.
That guy was.
I woulda got fucked in the ass for sure.
I have got killed.
He got killed because if this guy just
got out of jail,
he's probably tired of tattle tale on
kids and their bullshit,
you know,
it probably would have fucked me.
Kill me.
You know that company that has that
thing that you like.
Old people were like help.
I've fallen and I can't get up.
They should make that for kids like
help.
I'm getting fucked and I can't draw.
They should.
But kids are fucking liars,
man.
Be attached like boy scouts or something
like,
boy scouts will come rescue you instead.
Police.
There's those council.
Fuck you quicker than anybody.
Nobody was,
you fucking knew like this because you
lied about it.
Yeah.
You let dictionary rant.
Come on.
Yeah,
maybe there will be like a little camera
and microphones so that be like,
oh,
you aren't getting fucked.
We'll send somebody right now.
I think
gps tracking is a good idea.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean that's like the slippery slope.
The problem is you put a chip in your
kids so you could find out where they
are,
where they already called them with
phones,
you know those.
Yeah.
They have those.
But phones is big.
Devastating.
And a chip in your skin mean like a dog,
like a dog has a chip,
you know,
so I can if the,
if he gets going,
I think it's only if he goes to the vet,
if they pick them up at the pound,
the pound could scan them and the ship
has like a number to call.
But you know,
there's people that want to put like gps
chips in their kids so they could follow
their kids.
That's retarded.
It don't matter if your kid's not
retarded,
but the slippery slope is who else has
fallen you,
the executive government.
Anybody else?
Black helicopters you always hear about,
um,
a dudes who like attached gps to their
chicks car because they're stocking them
and they follow them.
They follow them around.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
it's a slippery slope because the,
the conductivity is unavoidable.
It's unavoidable that eventually there
will be no secrets.
I really believe that we've talked about
this before.
I think that eventually we're going to
be able to read each other's minds.
We're going to be able to access all the
information in the whole world,
not just on your phone,
not just a computer interface,
but you're going to be able to normally
access all this shit and that includes
as other people's thoughts.
You're going to have to share your
thoughts into the wave.
It sounds completely ridiculous.
Just sounds like total stoner talk,
but I don't think it sounds nearly as
ridiculous as the things we already
have,
like the large hadron collider or cell
phones or the ability to talk to
somebody on the other side of the world.
That's just as ridiculous to me.
I mean it's all ridiculous.
Sending pictures to the air high speed
video you can download.
You know what I mean?
I got wifi.
I sit on my laptop.
I can download like the ipad.
You download a movie and a couple of
minutes you could stream it.
Stream a movie alive.
What the fuck?
You can just go to netflix,
pick a movie and high definition loaded
up.
It plays.
There it is.
There's the movie.
You're getting it from the ether.
You're getting a fucking full movie.
You put your headphones on,
it's in stereo and you're getting it
from the sky.
That's insanity and that is just the
beginning.
It's gonna happen.
It's gonna.
The only.
If you look at the trend,
the number one trend is conductivity and
the instant access to information or the
more quicker access to information or
more access to information.
That's the trend.
It's like,
you know,
used to be libraries and then you know,
then then it was the internet and now
it's the internet on your phone and then
what else is next?
What's gonna come next?
It's going to be quicker,
easier,
faster,
more information like that,
that search engine where you can just
ask it questions and it comes up with
the answer.
What does that search engine called
being?
No,
there's a new one that they're working
on.
I'll find it on here.
I got it.
I saved it on evernote,
but they called it the google killer.
Now know what's going to be the best we
already talking about.
But the visual search.
This I think what's going to be big
visual search where you just take a
picture of something and it will google
search what it is.
Everything about it,
you know.
So like if you see like a,
I don't know if you see like a tennis
shoe on the ground,
you can take a picture of it and we'll
tell you what model of tennis shoe that
is,
you know,
where it's sold,
how much it is,
you know?
Yeah,
this is.
Yeah.
Yeah,
no,
I think you're right.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that wolfram alpha is the new thing.
W o l f r a m alpha and what it is,
is this thing that these guys have been
putting together for a while.
It's not totally done yet,
but the idea is that this is going to be
able to answer any question you have and
that you know,
I mean that really is the future that
they'll take the data,
the entire database of science,
the entire database of archeology,
history,
everything else.
Mathematics and literally put it into
some sort of a search engine where
you'll be able to ask the question.
You know,
what year was the first car invented?
What year was the first combustion
engine created?
You know,
when did they figure out that you could
turn the oil from the ground and the
gasoline?
How did they do it?
Who was the guy that shits gonna happen?
Man,
you're gonna.
You're gonna.
Be able to get any,
any answer to any question.
You literally never have to go to school
again.
I can't wait to the part where I can go
through my old photos from when I was
like five years old.
Hold it up to my webcam.
They go,
here's their facebook.
They now do this.
They look at this because there's so
many people that have lost touch with
and I don't know their name.
Babies.
What if it's a baby?
You can totally do it.
You're going to totally be able to do
that to the 100 percent.
How the baby grows up hundred percent.
Ten years or less.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
I think you're probably right.
Wow.
What's your fucking question?
Who this guy named carlos when see it as
a homo and needs to send his fans to
space with the other monkeys.
All right buddy.
Settle the fuck down.
Settle down.
You freak.
What is this guy saying?
You hate men.
Sia for stealing jokes,
but you still don't.
T rex joke.
Hypocrite.
I didn't sell steel shit.
See rex job.
Someone said that there was another guy
who was a joke about trx not being able
to jerk off this.
Wow.
How obvious is this that he can check
off?
Not the greatest connection in the
world,
but when you have small arms and you
can't grab your own dick,
I know anybody can come up with that
conclusion,
but what I had it in is a whole series
of things about masturbation.
Now masturbation is evolutionary and my
joke was that's why the t rex didn't
evolve because couldn't jerk off 100
percent my own.
Okay.
And there's a thing called parallel
thinking.
The difference between me and a guy like
me or most comics I've got ligaments.
Ia is most comics like dave attell is
famous for.
He comes up with a joke,
he'll call like a bunch of people and
say,
hey,
if you ever heard this before,
you've heard this before,
because sometimes guys come up with
jokes and even though you came up with
it on your own,
you don't know whether or not anybody
else has come up with it before.
It's very possible.
It's called parallel thinking,
but the difference between that and a
guy like matt cea or robin williams or
any of these other guys that have been
accused of doing it over and over again
is there so many fucking pieces of
evidence.
So many times people have said it.
So many people know bits that they've
ripped off and like with a guy like
robin williams,
they used to have it set up where there
was special.
When he would come to the room,
people would flash lights to make sure
that the comics onstage knew that he was
in the room.
When I was in boston,
I'm at catch a rising star and cambridge
robin williams came and I remember this
because I was really raw.
I was like an open mic or I'd only been
doing comedy like not even a year.
You got to piss and robin williams came
into the club and there was all these
comics that were like a big name.
Boston comics.
I think one of them was,
um,
you know what?
I don't want to say names because I'm
just,
I'm just guessing.
But there was a bunch of a boston
headliners in the room and none of them
would go on stage.
They wouldn't go on stage because they
knew that he was in there and that if
they did a good bit on that stage and
they were local guys,
there were local headliners,
but they were just local guys.
And this was before the internet.
This is before anything.
He would just go on the tonight show,
the next night,
do their bit.
And that bit was dead.
They could never do it again.
So it was a totally different era back
then.
But there's parallel thinking.
There's things that,
uh,
I've thought of before.
There's things that other people have
thought of before that I've already
done.
Like I've had friends,
you know,
do a bit and uh,
there,
I know they didn't steal it from me,
but I have to tell them like,
hey,
that's on my first album.
Like this.
The same exact sort of connection that
you just made.
Bobby slayton and I who bobby's a buddy
of mine,
but we both had a joke.
I mean,
it's the same connection about blow
jobs.
It was,
mine was on my 1999 cd.
I don't know when his was,
but uh,
he said to me like,
wow,
we have like a similar joke.
And the joke was about blowjobs that
blow jobs or a job.
That's why implies like jerking off.
See,
my joke was a drifting off.
Sounds like it's no big deal.
That's like,
you just,
you know,
was just quit at any minute.
Like,
what are you doing?
I was just dripping off like no big
deal.
You want to eat?
I'll just stop.
But a blow job sounds like there's much
more commitment.
Like it's a job,
like they're implies a work ethic,
but that like jerking off is way more
commitment involved the jerking off then
blowjobs because chicks will quit blow
jobs all the time.
Girls will quit,
their mouth gets tired.
They don't want to do it anymore,
but no dude quits while jerking off.
And there's like,
you know what I mean?
It's true.
Like just fucking finish that thing.
I have had like a half hard dick and be
like holding my breath and squeezing.
My boss tried to do anything to to
figure out a way to just get it over
with and then once you calm you just
feel so god damn pathetic.
But there's a lot of commitment involved
in jerking off for whatever reason.
Like that's shit wants to get out of
your body,
but I never for a second thought that
bobby stole a bit and he didn't think
that I saw the bit.
It's like it's kind of obvious blow job,
you know?
It's not the most clever connection
between it being a job.
You know what I mean?
It's right there.
It's in the fucking name.
The problem with [inaudible],
like when like that t rex thing,
that's just something that's a cartoon
online that I saw after the fact that
the story they haD jokes about,
you know that I mean that's just the
dumbest.
It's just obvious.
Troll and I think might know
probably just stupid or was just young
and he doesn't know.
I mean,
it's,
look,
you know,
people,
people have questions about the way
Comedy works and whenever someone is so
about plagiarism,
like I have been in,
you have been with that whole men see a
thing,
uh,
you know,
not like we set out to do that.
Not like we set out to be the guys that
are speaking up against comedy
plagiarism.
But let me tell you how many fucking
comedians were happy that,
that happened.
I mean,
I can't tell.
I've just got a text message from
christopher titus today.
Christopher titus was a friend of mine,
just sent me a text today and
christopher is a very funny comic.
And uh,
he sent me a text today saying that,
um,
he says,
hey man,
you were on npr today.
They played the whole carlos thing and
had two lawyers on talking about how
convenience protect our material.
Great job changing the world,
keep the flow.
And you get a copy of that.
Yeah.
This is a comic.
So,
and it's not just him.
I mean louis,
c,
k,
so the same thing,
you know,
uh,
brian posehn came up and hugged me and
said,
thank god for you joe rogan.
I mean I came,
todd glass came out to me and said it
was the greatest thing you've ever seen
in his life.
Like I can't tell you how many comics
have said this,
like we had a real problem for a long
time and the real problem is that these
networks can make money from god's
stealing if guys are good performers and
they wound up stealing people's shit.
They can make a lot of money.
And for comIcs literally it takes a long
ass time to create a bit like,
a bit like my bit about the tigers
killing the kid at the zoo in san
francisco.
The one that made it onto my last
special.
THat bit took a long time to get right.
There was a lot of shit involved in like
it went back and forth.
It changed,
morphed,
it got bigger,
it got smaller.
It took a long time before I came up
with the version that got onto
television.
It was a lot of work.
Somebody could have easily come in,
jacked.
My idea,
jack,
my premise jack,
the whole way I structured it,
set it up and just taking it for their
own and literally it's stealing.
They put it on television and now I
can't do it anymore because now if I do
it,
you know,
like when a minute cstl stuff,
he steals it like word for word,
you know,
oftentimes.
So like these poor folks,
like there are bits gone.
It's like it's got stole,
they got stolen,
somebody took their shit.
That's been a gigantic problem for us.
You know,
we didn't set out to be the ones to try
to put a fork in that and stop it,
but something had to happen and it did.
And it just so happens that it was us
and it's just,
just synchronicity.
Just the way the world works,
you know.
But um,
I can understand why someone would want
to like,
scrutinize me extra carefully because of
that.
I mean,
that only makes sense.
Put red bands balls to your mouth,
please.
You know what,
that is a fucking rude,
rude request.
Uh,
there's this kind of comic named Brian
Jarvis,
I don't know if you ever heard him.
He has the best joke ever for some
reason.
Comics all like to show their dicks to
each other,
but he has this thing where he'll put
his dick coming out of the top of his
pants like right here.
So just its head sticking out.
And he'd be like,
dude,
I fucking slammed my belly button in my
door.
Look at it and your belly button and you
look and you're like,
whoa,
wait,
do all the time.
I love that shit.
I mean I hate that shit,
but I love how everyone's so comics are
so committed to showing their dicks.
It's hilarious.
George lopez deal a bit from our.
no,
I don't think he did.
I think that thing that happened with
the George Lopez thing was that it was a
pretty obvious bit.
The thing with the rap thing about the
wall.
That's it.
That's a Fucking obvious job man.
And these dudes who do like mexican
material,
you know,
an illegal alien material like lopez,
his actors.
It's very funny,
but a lot of is latino stuff.
And that's thE kind of thing,
I mean,
he's got to think like that.
George has never been accused of being a
deep before that.
Not that I'm aware of,
but
he's not an obvIous joke.
there was like five comics that dead
that joe put them and see a thing meant
not only did ari open for him and do
that bit and he saw it and commented on
how he thought it was funny.
But that dumb fuck did the same
mannerisms that are like windows.
Excuse me.
That's how he does it.
And he's so dumb.
He does it the exact same way in our
video.
He even said he never opened up for me.
And then like three seconds later,
he what?
oh,
he forgot he was.
I mean,
he just likes to read that whole video.
He's got everything.
he's still sometimes says he's mexican.
Are we talking about ms?
See if there's no poor guy.
Poor guy.
Some people people
still get.
I still get caught up in it.
You know,
look,
there's,
there is,
there's always gonna be retards.
There's always gonna be dumb fucks.
Oh,
he's going to be choked faced.
There's always goIng to be everything,
man.
There's,
there's always,
there's always gonna be people who enjoy
stupid shit.
There's always going to be people who,
uh,
think nancy is hilarious and I suck.
That's all good,
man.
It's a fucking big world,
you know,
like what you like.
Who gives a fuck son?
Well,
you know what,
we're at five minutes and 13 seconds,
which means we just ate through two
hours.
So that's more than enough.
More than enough.
I'll look.
There's all this comedy stuff,
you know,
go,
go.
Let's you hear.
So instead of all this negative stuff,
crossman sia rules,
that's what he rules your mother.
This is,
um,
this is,
uh,
what I think there's,
there's great comics right now.
This is one of the best times ever for
standup comedy.
There's so many good guys.
There's bIll burr who is a hilarious
comic.
If you never heard his stuff before.
I did that.
I'm kevin and being april foolishness
show with him a couple of weekends ago.
Fucking dude is fantastic.
He's hilarious.
There's patton oswald,
who's one of my favorites.
He's goddamn hilarious.
All of his cds are great.
It's just an awesome writer,
stan hope.
Of course,
you know,
he's a classIc and nor did jim norton.
Hilarious louis ck.
Of course.
There's so many good comics now.
Now instead of thinking positive,
instead of thinking negative about guys
steal and bullshit and the problems with
this and that,
the positive thing is there's so much
good comedy now.
There's so many good comedians and if
you like my shit,
my neW thing just came out.
You could get.
It's talking monkeys In space.
It's on itunes.
You can get it on dvd.
Joe rogan.net.
[inaudible] dot net has all the links
and it's on amazon and it's number two
on itunes.
Comedy bitch.
Get my ass kicked by robin williams,
but that wasn't the point.
Is this good stuff?
Now?
That's what's important.
Positive,
not negative.
You fucking faggots.
All right.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
We had a good time.
Uh,
hope we answered all your questions.
I love you too,
your rule to you.
Crazy bItch.
And I'm all good.
Thanks.
And we'll see you next week as the
weekly podcast keeps welding.